So fell Peru. We gave her greed, hunger and the cross. Three gifts for the civilised life. The family groups that sang on the terraces are gone. In their place slaves shuffled underground and they don't sing there. Peru is a silent country, frozen in avarice. And so fell Spain, gorged with gold distended, now dying. And so fell you, general, my mast. whom men called the son of his own deeds. I'm the only one left now of that company, landowner, slave owner, and forty years from any time of hope. There's no joy in that, or in anything now.
秘鲁就这样沦陷了。我们给了她贪婪、饥饿和十字架。这是文明生活的三个礼物。那些曾在梯田上歌唱的家族群体已经消失了。取而代之的是在地下蹒跚而行的奴隶，而他们在那里并不歌唱。秘鲁是一个沉默的国家，冻结在贪婪之中。西班牙也随之沦陷，因吞噬黄金而膨胀，如今正走向死亡。你也一样，将军，我的桅杆，被人们称为自己功绩之子的人。如今，在那群人中，我是唯一幸存的一个，地主、奴隶主，距离任何希望的时刻都已经四十年了。这其中没有快乐，现在的一切中也没有快乐。
But then there's no joy in the world could match for me what I had when I first went with you across the water to find the gold country. And no pain like losing it. So that was Old Martin, the narrator in Peter Schaffer's play, The Royal Hunt of the Sun, who was banished Dominic in our last episode. It's so great to have him back on the show. And he's his customary cheery self.
但世界上没有任何快乐能比得上我第一次和你一起渡过大海去寻找黄金之国时的那种感觉。也没有什么痛苦能比得上失去它。刚才那是老马丁，彼得·谢弗的戏剧《太阳的皇家狩猎》中的叙述者，他在我们上一集中被放逐了。很高兴他能回到节目中。他还是他那惯常的开朗模样。
Everything's awful. Yeah, he's had a brilliant time. He's like the Wonsler at the end of the Lorax for Dr. Seuss fans. Yeah. He's responsible for ruining everything. Yes. I mean, that's what he basically says himself, isn't he, doesn't he? In that quotation, we've ruined everything.
一切都很糟糕。是的，他度过了一段辉煌的时光。对于苏斯博士的粉丝来说，他就像《罗拉克斯》结尾的万斯勒。是的。他要为毁掉一切负责。是的。我的意思是，这基本上就是他自己说的，不是吗？在那段引文中，我们毁掉了一切。
We arrived. We had a brilliant time. We've ruined everything for everybody. And then we all died. And is that a fair summary? Pretty much, yeah, pretty much. So this play, which was, we've used it a lot. I was actually in a production of it at school.
我们到了。我们度过了一段辉煌的时光。我们为所有人毁掉了一切。然后我们都死了。这是一个公平的总结吗？差不多，是的，差不多。所以这部戏，我们已经用过很多次了。我实际上在学校里参加过它的演出。
It was the first play I was ever in, the first proper play I was ever in. Who did you play? Please tell me how to whelper. No, no, no, this is going to really, you're going to really enjoy this. I played Vithente de Valverde. Did you, Dr. Valverde? Yeah, the deranged priest. Yeah, I do enjoy that.
这是我参加的第一部戏，我参加的第一部正式的戏。你演了谁？请告诉我怎么演的。不，不，不，你会非常喜欢这个的。我扮演了维森特·德·瓦尔韦德。是你，瓦尔韦德博士？是的，那个精神错乱的牧师。是的，我确实很喜欢那个角色。
So just on the play. The play is, in the 16. and it's very kind of anti-imperial in its themes. But its message, which is basically, you know, the whole thing has been a complete nightmare. It's charged with ambivalence and regret and horror what's happened to Peru. Its message would have been very familiar to the people who wrote the first accounts of the conquest in the 16th century. Well, it ultimately comes from Bartolome, Las Casas, who we may be hearing from. Well, not just Las Casas, though.
关于这部戏。这部戏是在16世纪，它的主题带有某种反帝国主义色彩。但它的信息，基本上就是，你知道，整件事完全是一场噩梦。它充满了对秘鲁所发生之事的矛盾心理、遗憾和恐惧。它的信息对于那些在16世纪写下第一批征服记录的人来说会非常熟悉。嗯，它最终来自巴托洛梅·德·拉斯·卡萨斯，我们可能会听到他的声音。嗯，不仅仅是拉斯·卡萨斯。
So it's not just churchmen and stuff who are writing this. people who had gone on the very, very first missions with Pizarro, when they write accounts of it, then it's not all jubilation and glory at all. No, but this is the, I mean, this is an English play by an English writer. Yeah, the Black Legend of Spain. Yeah. It kind of enters the bloodstream of Protestant countries, doesn't it?
所以不仅仅是教士之类的人在写这些。那些随皮萨罗进行最初几次任务的人，当他们写下记录时，根本不是什么欢呼和荣耀。不，但这是，我的意思是，这是一部由英国作家创作的英国戏剧。是的，西班牙的黑色传说。是的。它进入了新教国家的血液，不是吗？
It definitely does, but they don't get it from nowhere. They get it from the Spanish themselves. So where are we now? We are in the middle of 1537. Attaualpa is dead. The civil war is over. and his successor Manco has fled Cusco for the jungle of the Vilcabamba Valley. And among the Spanish themselves, so they're now up to about 4,000 in total.
确实如此，但他们并非凭空得来。他们是从西班牙人自己那里得来的。那么我们现在在哪里？我们正处于1537年中期。阿塔瓦尔帕死了。内战结束了。他的继任者曼科已经逃离库斯科，进入了比尔卡班巴山谷的丛林。在西班牙人自己中间，他们现在总数达到了约4000人。
So still a really tiny number, but increasing all the time, any pretense of unity has completely collapsed. So the conquistadors are effectively divided between Francisco Pizarro in Lima and Diego de la Magro, his business partner in Cusco, the divide that has been there since the very first episode of this series. And we ended last time by setting the scene for the showdown between these three characters, Manco in the jungle, Al-Magro in the Andean Highlands, and Pizarro on the coast. And let's start with a man who you might anticipate at this point is the favourite.
所以人数仍然非常少，但一直在增加，任何团结的假象都已经完全崩溃。因此，征服者实际上分裂为利马的弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗和库斯科的商业伙伴迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗，这种分裂从本系列的第一集开始就一直存在。我们上次结束时为这三个角色之间的摊牌设定了场景：丛林中的曼科、安第斯高地的阿尔马格罗，以及海岸上的皮萨罗。让我们从你可能预料到是目前热门人选的那个人开始。
And I think that's Al-Magro, because Al-Magro is in charge in Cusco in the capital. So to remind people just about his personality, we described him in the first episode. Al-Mangro is a short man, he's ugly, he's very hardy and resilient. His body covered in scars. He is a conceited, boastful man who dresses very flamboyantly. He's always been bitter because he feels like Pizarro has shut him out. He's gone off to Chile and absolutely disgraced himself by walking around with chain gangs full of people half dead, half alive.
我认为那是阿尔马格罗，因为阿尔马格罗在首都库斯科掌权。为了提醒大家他的个性，我们在第一集中描述过他。阿尔马格罗个子矮小，长相丑陋，非常坚韧。他的身体布满伤疤。他是一个自负、爱吹嘘的人，穿着非常浮夸。他一直很痛苦，因为他觉得皮萨罗把他排挤在外。他去了智利，带着一群半死不活的人到处走，彻底丢尽了脸面。
He has taken Gonzalo and Hernando Pizarro prisoner now in Cusco, and he is ready to win the whole game. What he wants to do is to march on the coast and deal with Pizzarro. Zaro. But he dared leave Kusko undefended with Mancoe just over the mountains in the jungle. So first, he thinks, well, we'll deal with Manco first. He sends troops to go and hunt Manco down. And he gets his lieutenant to do this. His lieutenant is a very dashing young conquistador, who we haven't met before in this story, who is called Rodrigo Ogonjas. He's leading 300 horsemen and foot soldiers. So Manco has gone over the mountains. And his men have tried to block the roads behind them with trees, and they've left some troops
他现在已经在库斯科俘虏了贡萨洛和埃尔南多·皮萨罗，他准备赢得整场比赛。他想做的是向海岸进军，处理掉皮萨罗。但他不敢在曼科就在山那边的丛林里的情况下让库斯科处于无防备状态。所以首先，他想，好吧，我们先处理曼科。他派军队去追捕曼科。他让他的副官去做这件事。他的副官是一位非常潇洒的年轻征服者，我们在故事中之前没见过，名叫罗德里戈·奥戈涅斯。他率领着300名骑兵和步兵。所以曼科已经翻过了山。他的人试图用树木封锁身后的道路，并留下了一些后卫部队来减缓追击。但奥戈涅斯轻松地解决了敌人，他穿过了乌鲁班巴河，追赶曼科前往丛林中的维特科斯镇，曼科在那里避难。当奥戈涅斯的人到达维特科斯时，他们发现的东西实际上救了曼科的命，我会这么说。曼科已经离开了那个城镇，但在镇上，西班牙人发现了两样他们喜欢发现的东西。一个是供奉着巨大金色太阳像的寺庙，他们立即忙着洗劫，另一个是一群受惊的维斯塔贞女式的公主。
of rearguard to slow the pursuit. But Argonias makes light work of the enemy, and he crosses the Uroba River, and he chases Manco towards the town of Vitkos in the jungle where Manco has taken refuge. And when Orgonius's men get to Vicco's, what they find actually saves Manco's life, I would say. So Manco has already moved on from the town, but in the town, the Spanish find two things they love finding. One is a temple with a giant golden image of the sun, which they immediately get to busy looting, and the other is a load of terrified kind of vestal virgin-style princesses.
（注：此段与上一段内容有重叠，已按原文顺序翻译）
The Spanish, as so often, let themselves down. They can't, you know, they can't restrain themselves. Instead of pressing on, they spent hours hanging around Vicoss behaving badly. And meanwhile, Vamanko, with his high priest, Villac Umu, who's his brother, and the most devoted of his wives and a handful of followers he heads on into the forest. Orgonia pursues him with his fastest horseman
西班牙人像往常一样让自己失望了。他们无法，你知道，他们无法克制自己。他们没有继续前进，而是花了几小时在维特科斯闲逛，表现得很糟糕。与此同时，曼科带着他的大祭司、他的兄弟维亚克·乌穆，以及他最忠诚的妻子和少数追随者进入了森林。奥戈涅斯带着他最快的骑兵追赶他。
but nights falling now and they can't find any trace of Manco in the jungle. And Argonius goes back to Vikos for the night and there he finds orders from Almagro already saying come back to Kusko, I need you back here at once. Now why does Almagro want him to come back? Because envoys have just arrived from Francisco Pizarro in Lima
但夜幕降临了，他们在丛林中找不到曼科的任何踪迹。奥戈涅斯回到维特科斯过夜，在那里他发现了阿尔马格罗的命令，说立刻回到库斯科，我需要你马上回来。那么阿尔马格罗为什么要他回来呢？因为利马的弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗派来的特使刚刚到达，试图解决他们之间的宿怨。阿尔马格罗心想，好吧，如果这是决定的时刻，我希望我最好的人手在身边。这对曼科来说是个好消息。曼科现在逃脱了，他可以冷静下来，准备反击。与此同时，在他做这些的时候，
to try to settle the feud between them. And Almagro thinks, okay, well, if this is the moment of decision, I want my best guy back at hand. So that's great news for Manko. Manko's now got away and he can kind of compose himself and prepare to fight back. Meanwhile, while he's doing that,
（注：此段与上一段内容有重叠，已按原文顺序翻译）
the feud between Almagro and Pizarro is reaching the moment of decision. So mid-September 1537, Almagro leads his troops out of Cusgo heading for the coast. And Dominic, the coast is a huge advantage that Pizarro has had over Amagro, isn't it? Because from the coast, he can receive reinforcements, but also he can write letters to the king in Spain, giving his side of the argument. And poor old Amalgro stuck up in Cusco hasn't been able to do either of those things. Exactly. Almagro, you could argue in a weird way, although I think you started as the favourite, it. The longer this goes on, the more it benefits Pizarro precisely because of Pizarro's links with the outside world, because Prasota is controlling those links. And as you say, people arriving all the
阿尔马格罗和皮萨罗之间的宿怨正达到决定的时刻。1537年9月中旬，阿尔马格罗率军离开库斯科前往海岸。多米尼克，海岸是皮萨罗相对于阿尔马格罗拥有的巨大优势，不是吗？因为从海岸，他可以获得增援，而且他还可以写信给西班牙国王，陈述他的论点。而可怜的阿尔马格罗困在库斯科，这两件事都做不到。确实。阿尔马格罗，你可以说以一种奇怪的方式，虽然我认为你开始时他是热门人选。这件事拖得越久，对皮萨罗就越有利，这正是因为皮萨罗与外部世界的联系，因为皮萨罗控制着这些联系。正如你所说，人们一直在到达，来自西班牙的补给、枪支、弩、一般物资，而且你还负责与宫廷的通讯。当然，在整个故事中，西班牙人那种疯狂的法律主义，你知道，法官总是宣布判决，起诉书被下达。他们在这一方面非常美国化。而且，我的意思是，皮萨罗对利马的占有，因此实际上对他来说是一个巨大的优势。所以阿尔马格罗，他有计划建立自己的城镇，不是吗？并称之为阿尔马格罗。是的，当然。这有点可爱，我想。所以阿尔马格罗带着他，记住他有人质，埃尔南多和贡萨洛。他带着埃尔南多，但他把贡萨洛留在了库斯科作为囚犯。这是阿尔马格罗三次可怕错误中的第一个。因为他一走，贡萨洛就打破塔楼逃跑了。所以这是第一个错误。阿尔马格罗到达海岸。在这里，一位名叫弗朗西斯科·德·博瓦迪利亚的托钵僧被任命为他和皮萨罗之间的仲裁者。基本上，宿怨归结为的问题是，谁控制库斯科城？
time, supplies from Spain, gums, crossbows, general stuff, but also you're in charge of communications back to the court. And of course, all through this story, the mad legalism of the Spanish, you know, judges are always pronouncing verdicts, indictments are being handed down. They're very American in that sort of respect. And, I mean, Pizarro's possession of Lima, therefore, is actually an enormous advantage for him. And so Amalgro, he's got plans to set up his own town, hasn't he? And call it Amalgro. Yeah, of course. Which is kind of sweet, I guess. So Almagro brings with him, remember he's got the two brothers hostage, Enando and Gonzalo. He brings Anando with him, but he leaves
（注：此段与上一段内容有重叠，已按原文顺序翻译）
Gonzalo behind and Cusco as a prisoner. This is the first of three terrible mistakes by Elmago, because as soon as he's gone, Gonzalo breaks out of the tower and escapes. So that's mistake number one. Almagro arrives at the coast. Here, a mendicant friar called Francisco de Bobadilla has been appointed to arbitrate between him and Pizarro. And basically, the issue that the feud has boiled down to is, who controls the city of Kusco?
Does it fall in New Castile, Peru, which is Pizarro? Or does it fall in New Toledo, which kind of chilly, which would mean it's Almagros? And these negotiations don't go well, do they? Because there are Spaniards who say that the friar had been possessed by a demon who wished to show dissent among the Spaniards. That's possibly true. I'm guessing that they don't really patch things up. No, they don't.
它属于新卡斯蒂利亚，秘鲁，也就是皮萨罗的吗？还是属于新托莱多，也就是智利，这意味着它是阿尔马格罗的？这些谈判进行得并不顺利，对吧？因为有西班牙人说这位修士被一个希望在西班牙人中制造异议的恶魔附身了。这可能是真的。我猜他们并没有真正解决问题。不，他们没有。
And another way of describing this demon-inspired negotiation is that Al-Mag... Basically, at this point, Pizarro and Al-Magro cannot stand. each other. They absolutely despise each other. And Al Magro, as soon as they start negotiating, massively loses the plot, has a colossal tantrum and a meltdown, and storms out. This is a great mistake, because basically that leaves the friar surrounded by Pizarro and Pizarro's armed men. And the friar at this point says, okay, well, maybe I guess you should have Cusco? Yeah, actually, on reflection, I think Cusco does belong to you. Pizarro is very shrewd throughout. I don't think he's at sort of Cortez levels of
另一种描述这种恶魔启发的谈判的方式是，阿尔马格罗……基本上，在这一点上，皮萨罗和阿尔马格罗无法忍受对方。他们绝对鄙视对方。阿尔马格罗，一旦他们开始谈判，就彻底失去了理智，大发雷霆，崩溃了，冲了出去。这是一个巨大的错误，因为基本上这让修士被皮萨罗和皮萨罗的武装人员包围了。修士在这一点上说，好吧，也许我猜你应该拥有库斯科？是的，实际上，反思一下，我认为库斯科确实属于你。皮萨罗在整个过程中非常精明。我不认为他达到了科尔特斯那种冷酷、滑头狡猾的程度。但皮萨罗是一个非常好的扑克玩家。皮萨罗给阿尔马格罗发了一条信息，他说，看，你知道，我们有分歧。我认为寻求第二意见才公平。你知道，我不想马上要求这座城市。我想从一位皇家官员那里得到第二意见。如果你放了我的兄弟埃尔南多，我准备这样做。如果你放了埃尔南多，我保证我会直接把埃尔南多送回西班牙。阿尔马格罗，他一定是……我的意思是，考虑到他是一个征服者，而且他沉浸在鲜血中，
cold, slippery cunning. But Pizarro is a very good poker player. And Pizarro sends a message to Elmagnar and he says, look, you know, we've had our differences. I think it would only be fair to get a second opinion. You know, I don't want to claim the city straight away. I'd like to get a second opinion from a royal official. And I'm prepared to do that if you'll let my brother Hernando go. And if you let Hernando go, I promise I will send Hernandez straight back to Spain. And Al-Magro, who must be the most... I mean, given that he's a conquistador and that he's steeped in blood,
（注：此段与上一段内容有重叠，已按原文顺序翻译）
he must be the most gullible person on the planet because he says, oh, yeah, okay, well, that sounds like a good deal. And he immediately releases Enando, which means he's lost his leverage, because now he doesn't have either of the Pizarro brothers hostage. And Anando, does he head for the coast and go to Spain? Of course he doesn't.
他一定是这个星球上最容易受骗的人，因为他说，哦，是的，好吧，这听起来是个好交易。他立即释放了埃尔南多，这意味着他失去了筹码，因为现在他没有埃尔南多或贡萨洛·皮萨罗作为人质了。埃尔南多，他前往海岸并去西班牙了吗？他当然没有。
He immediately musters 700 Spaniards, and thousands of native auxiliaries. Because remember, Orlando, Anando has always, although he was the defender of Kusko, he was always the Spaniard who got on best with the locals. You remember he'd gone on well with Atta Walper.
他立即召集了700名西班牙人和数千名土著辅助人员。因为记住，埃尔南多，虽然他是库斯科的保卫者，但他一直是与当地人相处得最好的西班牙人。你记得他与阿塔瓦尔帕相处得很好。
He tried hard with Manco. He's clearly, he's the most sort of sympathetic and the most diplomatic. The most diplomatic. Anyway, Anando marches on Kusko, and Almagro's army is waiting for him. Almagro is not leading them, he's fallen ill, possibly I think with syphilis, which I think reflects poorly on his general
他与曼科努力过。他显然是那种最富有同情心、最外交的人。最外交的人。总之，埃尔南多向库斯科进军，阿尔马格罗的军队正在等他。阿尔马格罗没有领导他们，他病倒了，我可能认为是梅毒，我认为这反映了他糟糕的总体行为。他潇洒的副手罗德里戈·奥戈涅斯负责指挥。现在奥戈涅斯犯了他自己的错误。阿尔马格罗的军队在骑兵和马匹方面非常强大。他基本上负责选择这场战斗的地点来面对埃尔南多的军队。他选择了旧印加盐矿的地点。但地形非常破碎，崎岖不平。对马匹不利，但对埃尔南多的军队有利，主要是步兵和帝国火枪手。而且，它非常好的另一件事是，因为它像一个圆形剧场，
conduct. And his dashing deputy, Rodrigo Orgonius, is in command. And now Agonius makes a mistake of his own. Amagro's army is very strong in cavalry and horses. And he basically is in charge of choosing the site for this battle to face Enando's army. And he chooses the site of some old Inca salt mines. But the terrain is very broken and kind of jagged and rugged. Not good for horses, but it is good for Anandos army, which is mainly infantry and imperial gunmen, Archibusias. And also, the other thing it's very good for, because it's like a kind of an amphitheater,
（注：此段与上一段内容有重叠，已按原文顺序翻译）
a natural amphitheater, is for spectators. And loads of natives turn up, don't they? And kind of cheer on both sides, because they want all Spaniards to wipe each other. out if only both sides could lose. So basically all, everything that follows, you have to mention everything that follows in this episode, there's generally about 10,000 people watching from the hailsides and kind of cheering, eating snacks and kind of, it's the most tremendous spectator sport. So what follows, it's the 6th April 1538. It's called the Battle of Las Salinas, and it takes just two hours. And I've restrained myself throughout this series from quoting from this guy, but I'm
一个天然的圆形剧场，适合观众。大量的土著出现了，不是吗？并为双方加油，因为他们希望所有西班牙人互相消灭，如果只有双方都能输就好了。所以基本上所有，接下来发生的一切，你必须提到这一集中接下来发生的一切，通常有大约10,000人在山坡上观看，并欢呼，吃零食，这是一种最了不起的观赏性运动。所以接下来发生的是，1538年4月6日。它被称为拉斯萨利纳斯战役，只持续了两个小时。我在整个系列中一直克制自己不引用这个人的话，但我最终要屈服并这样做。有一位19世纪的美国历史学家叫威廉·H·普雷斯科特，美国人认为他绝对了不起。他写了关于印加征服的最极其华丽的记录。我要……嗯，实际上，汤姆，你很擅长这种19世纪的声音。所以你为什么不读一下呢？这是他对战斗的描述。斗争是绝望的。因为那不是白人对无助印第安人的斗争，而是西班牙人对西班牙人的斗争。双方都用他们的战斗口号“国王与阿尔马格罗”或“国王与皮萨罗”为他们的同志加油，同时他们以一种民族反感都无法比拟的仇恨进行战斗，这种仇恨的强烈程度与被撕裂的纽带的强度成正比。这太棒了。19世纪美国的那些人正在为那段文字擦去充满男子气概的泪水，不是吗？所以无论如何，这个家伙，奥戈涅斯，他战斗，用威廉·H·普雷斯科特的话说，像一个浪漫的圣骑士。但随后他的脸被火枪射中。他被撞下马。他站起来，当他站起来时，他被埃尔南多·皮萨罗的人包围了。奥戈涅斯，他显然只是在错误的世纪。他基本上是堂吉诃德，不是吗？
going to finally give in and do it. There's a 19th century American historian called William H. Prescott, who Americans think is absolutely amazing. And he wrote the most tremendously florid account of the conquest of the Inca's. And I'm going to... Well, actually, Tom, you do this sort of 19th century voice very well. So why don't you read it? This is his account of the battle. The struggle was desperate. For it was not that of the white man against the defenseless Indian, but of Spaniard against Spaniard. Both parties cheering on their comrades with their battle cries of El Rey e Al-Magro or El Rey E Pizarro while they fought with a hate
（注：此段与上一段内容有重叠，已按原文顺序翻译）
to which national antipathy was as nothing a hate strong in proportion to the strength of the ties that had been rent asunder. That's brilliant. There's people in 19th century America wiping away tears of manly emotion at that prose, aren't there? So anyway, this guy or great,
Agaigonez, he fights, in the words of William Hadesk, like a paladin of romance. But then he's hit in the face by a shot from an archibus. And he's knocked off his horse. And he gets up, and by the time he gets up, he's surrounded by Anando Pizarre's men. And Agonius, who clearly is just in the wrong century. He's Don Quixote, basically, isn't he?
（注：此段与上一段内容有重叠，已按原文顺序翻译）
Yeah, he's been reading too many chivalric romances. And he says, is there a knight to whom I can surrender? And a bloke called Fuentes steps forward, and he says, he puts a bit out, He says, you know, I'm a knight. He isn't. And Agonius ceremoniously hands him his sword. Fuentes takes his sword, then he draws his knife and stabs Organes through the heart.
是的，他读了太多的骑士传奇。他说，有我可以投降的骑士吗？一个叫富恩特斯的人走上前，他说，他伸出一只手，他说，你知道，我是个骑士。他不是。奥戈涅斯庄重地把剑递给他。富恩特斯接过他的剑，然后拔出刀，刺穿了奥戈涅斯的心脏。
And then they cut off his head and stick it on a pike and parade around the battlefield with his head on a pike. Heart of darkness. Very hard to darkness. So at this point, Almagro's forces, they're sort of the flower of chivalry who was leading them, has basically been stabbed and had his head cut off. They all flee for Cusco, including El Mald. Agro himself who's been watching in horror and in syphilitic agony from his litter, the Pizarro troops catch up with him and they lock him in the same tower in which he had imprisoned Ernando.
然后他们砍下他的头，把它插在长矛上，带着他的头在战场上游行。黑暗之心。非常黑暗之心。所以此时，阿尔马格罗的军队，他们那种领导他们的骑士之花，基本上被刺伤并被砍下了头。他们都逃往库斯科，包括阿尔马格罗本人，他一直在他的轿子里惊恐地看着，处于梅毒的痛苦中，皮萨罗的军队追上了他，他们把他锁在囚禁埃尔南多的同一个塔楼里。
So poetic justice. Poetic justice. Just a side point on this battle, actually, the Battle of Las Salinas. Apparently, it's regarded as one of the last medieval battles, decided with lances and cavalry charges. Well, isn't that good news for the watching fans? Yeah. You turn up to watch a battle and it's the last medieval battle.
所以诗意的正义。诗意的正义。关于这场战斗的一个侧面观点，实际上，拉斯萨利纳斯战役。显然，它被认为是最后一场中世纪战役之一，由长矛和骑兵冲锋决定。嗯，这对观看的粉丝来说不是好消息吗？是的。你出现观看一场战斗，而这是最后一场中世纪战役。
Right, because future battles will be, there'll be loads of artillery and pikes and stuff, so much more early modern. But this is on old school battles. They put on an old school treat for the watching crowds, which is nice. That's great. So for 10 weeks, Diego de la Magro, who thought he had it all, is rotting in prison. And then he's dragged out for trial. And I described him earlier as very naive and gullible. And I think he is because he thinks, you know, we're going to have more negotiations.
对，因为未来的战斗将会有大量的火炮和长矛之类的东西，所以更接近近代早期。但这属于老派战斗。他们为观看的人群上演了一场老派的盛宴，这很好。太棒了。所以十周以来，迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗，那个以为自己拥有一切的人，在监狱里腐烂。然后他被拖出来受审。我之前形容他非常天真和容易受骗。我认为他是，因为他认为，你知道，我们将会有更多的谈判。
You know, this will all be fine. And he is absolutely dumbfounded when Anandouper. when Anando Pizarro says to him, you're a rebel, you know, you're a traitor against the king. I proclaim the death sentence upon you. This is the end of you. And Armagro breaks down in tears. He begs for his life. He says to Anando, suspend the sentence so that I can appeal to Charles the Fifth,
你知道，这一切都会好起来的。当埃尔南多·皮萨罗对他说，你是个叛军，你知道，你是反对国王的叛徒。我宣布对你判处死刑。这是你的终点。阿尔马格罗泪流满面。他乞求活命。他对埃尔南多说，暂停判决，以便我可以向查理五世上诉，
per pardon. So that legalism again. Yeah, the legalism. You let the wheels of justice take time. And Anando says to him, come on. This is very demeaning and unbecoming from you. Anando said to him at one point, what do you think this is? What game do you think you're playing?
请求宽恕。所以又是那种法律主义。是的，法律主义。你让正义的轮子花时间。埃尔南多对他说，得了吧。这太卑鄙了，对你来说不体面。埃尔南多有一次对他说，你以为这是什么？你以为你在玩什么游戏？
He says, God gave you the grace to be a Christian, so please employ your remaining moments in settling your accounts with heaven, because you're for the chop. And the appointed day is the 8th of July 1538. Enando sends the executioner to Almagro's cell. The executioner goes in. He garots Almagro and then they drag his body outside. They strip him naked and then they cut off his head. So you might think this is the end of the Pizarro-Magro feud.
他说，上帝给了你成为基督徒的恩典，所以请利用你剩下的时间来处理你与天堂的账目，因为你要被砍头了。指定的日子是1538年7月8日。埃尔南多派刽子手去阿尔马格罗的牢房。刽子手进去了。他勒死了阿尔马格罗，然后他们把他的尸体拖到外面。他们剥光他的衣服，然后砍下他的头。所以你可能认为这是皮萨罗-阿尔马格罗宿怨的终结。
Exciting news, it isn't. This is a proper vendetta and we'll go through the generations. We'll come back to this point. So now Kusko belongs to the Pizarros and their new puppet. Now you may remember that at the end of the last episode, Almagro had a puppets called Paolu, a collaborator. Paolu's men had fought for Al-Magro at Las Salinas. But as soon as they saw that the Pizarros had won,
令人兴奋的消息，它不是。这是一场真正的世仇，我们将代代相传。我们将回到这一点。所以现在库斯科属于皮萨罗家族和他们的新傀儡。现在你可能记得在上一集结束时，阿尔马格罗有一个叫保卢的傀儡，一个合作者。保卢的人在拉斯萨利纳斯为阿尔马格罗而战。但一旦他们看到皮萨罗赢了，
Paulu immediately switched sides. And he said to Anando Pizarro, look, I was pals with Almagra. I served him very loyally. I'll serve you loyly now, if you like. And Anando, who's a smart man, said, great, yeah, why not? Let's do it.
保卢立即倒戈。他对埃尔南多·皮萨罗说，看，我和阿尔马格罗是朋友。我非常忠诚地为他服务。如果你愿意，我现在也会忠诚地为你服务。埃尔南多，一个聪明人，说，太好了，是的，为什么不呢？让我们这样做。
So in return for collaborating Paolu, the sort of fake emperor, they built him his own Spanish-style townhouse. He got his own Spanish-style landed estate, and they gave him a Spanish coat of arms. And I quote, a black eagle rampant, a gold puma, two red snakes, a red imperial fringe, the inscription Ave Maria and eight golden Jerusalem crosses.
所以作为合作的回报，保卢，那个假皇帝，他们为他建造了自己的西班牙式联排别墅。他得到了自己的西班牙式庄园，他们给了他一个西班牙纹章。我引用一下，一只黑鹰腾空，一只金美洲狮，两条红蛇，一条红色帝国流苏，铭文“圣母玛利亚”和八个金色耶路撒冷十字架。
That's too much action. I think that's great. No, I think less is more. Do you? Yeah, with a heraldic coat of arms. So you wouldn't fit in in Peru. They'd think more is more. So Paolo ends up wearing Spanish clothes.
那动作太多了。我认为那太棒了。不，我认为少即是多。是吗？是的，带有纹章。所以你不会适合秘鲁。他们会认为多即是多。所以保卢最终穿上了西班牙服装。
He converts to Christianity. And actually, he disgraces himself in one way. He hands over to the Spaniards, the mummified remains of his father, Hwena Capac. God, he is a snake, isn't he? The last unchallenged Inca emperor, he hands them over. And apparently we're told that his mother and his other relatives sobbed and said, please don't hand this over. The Spanish will just burn it and destroy it, which they did.
他皈依了基督教。实际上，他在一方面丢尽了脸面。他把父亲瓦伊纳·卡帕克的木乃伊遗骸交给了西班牙人。天哪，他真是条毒蛇，不是吗？最后一位未受挑战的印加皇帝，他把他们交出去了。显然有人告诉我们，他的母亲和其他亲戚啜泣着说，请不要交出这个。西班牙人只会烧毁并摧毁它，他们确实这样做了。
And Paolo said, I don't care. I'm all about winning. And I have. I've won. So that's the end of that. And he did. And Kusko itself is in a terrible way by this point, because it's been kind of demolished.
保卢说，我不在乎。我只关心赢。而且我赢了。所以这就是结局。他确实赢了。库斯科本身在这一点上处于可怕的状态，因为它被拆毁了。
Everything's been stripped off. It's been burnt by red hot slingshot. So an absolute, I mean, wasted. But if you go to Kusko today, Kusko is a very attractive city, but it's a Spanish colonial city. There's nothing of the Incan city. There are bits. So there are bits of wall and stuff. There are bits of temple wall and things.
一切都被剥光了。它被红热的弹弓烧毁了。所以绝对，我的意思是，荒废了。但如果你今天去库斯科，库斯科是一个非常有吸引力的城市，但它是一个西班牙殖民城市。印加城市什么都没有了。有一些碎片。所以有一些墙壁之类的东西。有一些寺庙墙壁之类的东西。
A little bit like in Mexico city. But by and large, what you're seeing is, you know, you're not seeing thatched houses that were built by the Inca's. So what's happened to Manco, Paolo's predecessor, half brother and now rival? Manco has been off in the jungle after his close shave at Viccos and he now launches a series of attacks across the Andes Tom you'll enjoy this he's particularly keen to punish tribes who have sided with the Spaniards your old friends the huanka this is not good for the huanka they are brought back he captures lots of them
有点像墨西哥城。但总的来说，你所看到的是，你知道，你没有看到印加人建造的茅草屋。那么曼科，保卢的前任、同父异母的兄弟，现在是竞争对手，发生了什么？曼科在维特科斯死里逃生后一直躲在丛林里，他现在在安第斯山脉发动了一系列袭击。汤姆，你会喜欢这个的，他特别热衷于惩罚那些站在西班牙人一边的部落，你的老朋友万卡人。这对万卡人来说不是好消息，他们被带回来了，他俘虏了他们中的许多人
and brings them back into the jungle at Viccos for punishment and we're told his men tortured them in the presence of their women so after the next couple of years this degenerates into this colossal guerrilla campaign fought over a vast canvas. So the Pizarro brothers basically battling Manco's forces and other kind of native forces, everywhere from the Andes down to Lake Titicacaa, the great sort of plateau of Bolivia and so on, these huge landscapes. But also fast distances. Massive distance. I mean, we're talking about hundreds and hundreds of miles. Over incredibly inhospitable terrain. Bonkers. One of the decisive battles, just give you an example,
并把他们带回维特科斯的丛林进行惩罚，我们被告知他的人在他们的女人面前折磨他们。所以在接下来的几年里，这演变成了一场在广阔画布上进行的巨大游击战。所以皮萨罗兄弟基本上在与曼科的军队和其他土著军队作战，从安第斯山脉到的的喀喀湖，玻利维亚的大高原等等，这些巨大的景观。但也距离遥远。巨大的距离。我的意思是，我们谈论的是数百英里。在极其不适宜居住的地形上。疯了。决定性的战斗之一，给你举个例子，
One example of how this works is a place in central Bolivia called Cochabamba. And there, Gonzalo finds himself trapped in a valley by thousands of sort of Bolivian indigenous warriors. And it looks really dicey for him. But he's got with him, Paolu and 5,000 indigenous warriors from Kusko. And he ends up winning. And it's a really good example of how much indigenous support mattered to the Spanish conquest. because one Spanish writer Alonzo de Toro said, if Paolo had not been there, the Spaniards would have suffered heavily,
一个例子说明它是如何运作的，是玻利维亚中部一个叫科恰班巴的地方。在那里，贡萨洛发现自己被数千名玻利维亚土著战士困在一个山谷里。对他来说看起来真的很危险。但他带着保卢和5000名来自库斯科的土著战士。他最终赢了。这是一个很好的例子，说明土著支持对西班牙征服有多重要。因为一位西班牙作家阿隆索·德·托罗说，如果保卢不在那里，西班牙人会遭受重创，
and if he had chosen to be treacherous, few or none of them would have escaped. But Paolo has already decided to know, Spanish is going to win, so I'm going to stick with them. And he does, and they hold out, and they basically end up wiping the floor with the people attacking them. So by the middle of 1539, I mean, we're only seven years after Pizarro marched into Kayamaka to meet Atta whalper.
如果他选择背叛，他们中很少或没有人能逃脱。但保卢已经决定知道，西班牙人会赢，所以我将坚持与他们在一起。他确实这样做了，他们坚持住了，他们基本上最终把攻击他们的人打得落花流水。所以到1539年中期，我的意思是，我们距离皮萨罗走进卡哈马卡会见阿塔瓦尔帕只有七年。
The Pizarros are actually pretty close to finishing the job. They've pacified Ecuador. They beat the bloke with his drum and whatnot. They've subdued most of Peru and Bolivia. They've got from Charles V, the seal of approval, because Francisco Pizarro has been made a Marquist. And he's got a very... A mad coat of arms.
皮萨罗家族实际上非常接近完成这项工作。他们平定了厄瓜多尔。他们打败了那个拿着鼓的家伙等等。他们征服了秘鲁和玻利维亚的大部分地区。他们从查理五世那里得到了批准印章，因为弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗被封为侯爵。他有一个非常……疯狂的纹章。
Yeah, a mad coat of arms. A coat of arms that shows Attawalpa with a metal collar with his hands plunged into two great chests of gold. So very on the nose. Like Pizarro's not. But he's out and proud. Yeah. Basically a coat of ours that combines gold and garotting.
是的，一个疯狂的纹章。一个显示阿塔瓦尔帕戴着金属项圈，双手插进两个大金箱子的纹章。所以非常直白。就像皮萨罗不是。但他公开且自豪。是的。基本上是一个结合了黄金和绞刑的纹章。
Yeah. Which is what he's all about. That sums it up, really, doesn't it? Yeah. What they haven't done there, the Pizarro, is find Manko. So Manko has retreated even deeper into the jungle. And we have a tremendous source. His son, Tito Kuzi, will come back to his son in the second half.
是的。这就是他的全部。这总结了它，不是吗？是的。他们没有做的是找到曼科。所以曼科撤退到了丛林更深处。我们有一个了不起的来源。他的儿子，蒂托·库西，我们将在下半部分回到他的儿子。
His son is a great character. His son said of him, him. He returned to the town of Vittcos, and from there he went to Vilcabamba, so that's below Vichos in the jungle, where he remained for some days, and he built houses and palaces to make it his principal residence for it has a warm climate, because it's deep in the rainforest. And Vilcabamba, which is sort of further down from Vichos, was chosen for its remoteness and its safety. They thought there was basically no way the Spanish could find them in the heart of the jungle. And it's Vilka Bamba that becomes the ultimate lost city of the Inca's.
他的儿子是一个了不起的角色。他的儿子说，他。他回到了维特科斯镇，从那里他去了比尔卡班巴，所以那是维特科斯下方丛林中的地方，他在那里待了几天，他建造了房屋和宫殿，使它成为他的主要住所，因为它气候温暖，因为它在雨林深处。而比尔卡班巴，它在维特科斯更下方，因其偏远和安全而被选中。他们认为基本上西班牙人没有办法在丛林中心找到他们。而比尔卡班巴成为了印加人最终的失落之城。
So the site today is called Espiritu Pampa. But it's totally cut off. Like you can't drive there. And actually, if anyone was interested, our friend Michael Wood, who's been on The Rest is History, did a TV series in the 1990s called Conquistadors. He did an episode about Peru. And he literally hacks his way through the jungle in the sort of second half of that episode to get to this site and kind of does pieces.
所以今天的遗址被称为埃斯皮里图潘帕。但它完全被切断了。就像你不能开车去那里。实际上，如果有人感兴趣，我们的朋友迈克尔·伍德，他参加过《历史的其余部分》，在1990年代制作了一个名为《征服者》的电视系列。他制作了一集关于秘鲁的节目。他在那一集的下半部分字面上在丛林中开辟道路到达这个遗址，并做了一些片段。
camera from the ruins. It's really good telly and very sort of powerful. Anyway, so that's where Manco is. In April 1539, the pizarres decided they'd make another attempt to try and find him. And Gonzalo and Paolo set off from Cusco with 300 men to track him down. And they were pretty confident they could get in. They thought he was hemmed in, there's no chance of escape, all this. They hacked their way through the jungle. They survive an ambush by some Incas who roll boulders down the hill at them. That old boulder trick that the Inkers are now very addicted to. And they think they've got him cornered in a jungle fort called Chukiluska. But once again, Manco slips away. It's very, I mean, this is very Hollywood. He ends up swimming across a river to
来自废墟的摄像机。这是非常好的电视，非常有力。总之，这就是曼科所在的地方。1539年4月，皮萨罗决定他们会再次尝试找到他。贡萨洛和保卢带着300人从库斯科出发去追踪他。他们非常有信心能进去。他们认为他被围困了，没有逃脱的机会，所有这些。他们在丛林中开辟道路。他们幸存了一次印加人的伏击，印加人把巨石滚下山坡。印加人现在非常沉迷的那种旧巨石把戏。他们认为他们把他困在了一个叫楚基卢斯卡的丛林堡垒里。但曼科再次溜走了。这非常，我的意思是，这非常像好莱坞。他最终游过一条河去
escape them. And then he gets out of the river. He stands on the other bank. And he taunts them across the river and he shouts at them, I am Manco Inca. I am Manco Inca. I have already killed 2,000 Spaniards. One day, I will kill the rest of you and I will take back the lands of my forefathers. So he's got away, but his sister, stroke wife, Cura Oclo, who we heard about in the previous episode, seized, raped, horrible. Even worse things now happen. And again, you know, if you've got your children with you, watch out. So basically, yes, you're right. Gonzalo Pizarro had taken a fancy to her in Cusco and had behaved poorly.
逃脱他们。然后他从河里出来。他站在另一岸。他隔着河嘲笑他们，他向他们大喊，我是曼科·印加。我是曼科·印加。我已经杀死了2000名西班牙人。有一天，我会杀死你们剩下的所有人，我会夺回我祖先的土地。所以他逃脱了，但他的姐妹兼妻子库拉·奥克洛，我们在上一集中听说过，被抓住，强奸，可怕。现在发生了更糟糕的事情。而且，你知道，如果你带着孩子，小心。所以基本上，是的，你是对的。贡萨洛·皮萨罗在库斯科看上了她，表现得很糟糕。
She's had a terrible time. now they catch her again and they drag her back to the sacred valley and basically all the way they keep trying to rape her again and her nephew Tito Kuzzi said she defended herself fiercely throughout and she covered her body with filth I think we know what he means so that the men who were trying to rape her would be nauseated
她度过了一段可怕的时光。现在他们再次抓住她，把她拖回圣谷，基本上他们一路上一直试图再次强奸她，她的侄子蒂托·库西说她自始至终激烈地反抗，她用污秽覆盖自己的身体，我想我们知道他的意思，这样那些试图强奸她的男人就会感到恶心。
she defended herself like this many times during the journey so they get back and Francisco Pizarro wants to use her as a hostage to get Manco to surrender. And he sends messengers to Manco with gifts of a pony that he's imported over the sea and some silk, some nice silk. And he says to Manco, come on, you know, give yourself up and I'll let your wife go. Manco kills all the people bringing in their messages.
她在旅途中多次这样反抗，所以他们回去了，弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗想利用她作为人质让曼科投降。他派信使带着他从海上进口的小马和一些丝绸，一些漂亮的丝绸给曼科。他对曼科说，得了吧，你知道，投降吧，我会放了你的妻子。曼科杀死了所有带来这些信息的人。
He says, I'm not, you know, we don't do deals with terrorists. And Pizarro is furious. And he decides to take his revenge on Kura Oklo, Manco's wife. They strip her naked and they tie her to a stake. there we're told she is beaten and abused by canyari Indians, so native allies. And her last words are quoted as, hurry up and put an end to me so that your appetites can be fully satisfied. They shoot her with arrows, they put her body in a basket, and they floated along the river into the jungle to Manco. Tito Cousy says Mancoe wept and made great morning for her, for he
他说，我不会，你知道，我们不与恐怖分子做交易。皮萨罗大怒。他决定对曼科的妻子库拉·奥克洛进行报复。他们剥光她的衣服，把她绑在柱子上。在那里，我们被告知她被卡尼亚里印第安人，也就是土著盟友殴打和虐待。她的遗言被引用为，快点结束我，这样你们的欲望就能得到充分满足。他们用箭射她，把她的尸体放在篮子里，顺着河漂进丛林给曼科。蒂托·库西说曼科为她哭泣并进行了巨大的哀悼，因为他
loved her very much. But Manco never does give himself up, and we'll find out what happens to him after the break. But before that, let's move on two years to the summer of 1541 and to the Pizarros. So, they're now for, what, nine years since they met Attawalpa. And they look like they've won. Francisco is the governor in Lima. Gonzalo is his lieutenant governor in Quito in Ecuador. And Anando has gone back to Spain to represent them at court. Francisco, the man we began this whole series with, the man from nowhere, you know, the world west of Spain and through, He's 63 years old. He's one of the richest men in the world. He has achieved his dreams more completely even than his cousin, Enan Cortez. As one chronicler Lopez de Gomara says,
非常爱她。但曼科从未投降，我们将在休息后找出他发生了什么。但在那之前，让我们向前推进两年到1541年的夏天，看看皮萨罗家族。所以，他们现在，距离他们见到阿塔瓦尔帕已经九年了。他们看起来好像赢了。弗朗西斯科是利马的总督。贡萨洛是他在厄瓜多尔基多的副总督。埃尔南多已经回到西班牙在宫廷代表他们。弗朗西斯科，我们开始整个系列的那个男人，那个来自虚无的男人，你知道，西班牙以西的世界，他63岁了。他是世界上最富有的人之一。他实现梦想的程度甚至比他的表弟埃尔南·科尔特斯更彻底。正如一位编年史家洛佩斯·德·戈马拉所说，
he had found and acquired more gold and silver than any of the many Spaniards who crossed to the Indies and more than any commander in the history of the world. I think that possibly is true. I mean, colossal quantities. Amazing thing about Pizarro. Pizarro remember, illegitimate, illiterate, you know, as a young man, as a boy, herded pigs. He has achieved all this by, of course, ambition and violence, but also by cunning and kind of cool, shrewd calculation. He's not a lovable man, that's for sure. But he's not as slippery as Cortez's, and he's not as bloodthirsty as Pedro de Elvarado.
他发现并获得了比任何跨越到印度的西班牙人，以及历史上任何指挥官都多的黄金和白银。我认为这可能是真的。我的意思是，巨大的数量。关于皮萨罗的惊人之处。记住皮萨罗，私生子，文盲，你知道，作为一个年轻人，作为一个男孩，放猪。他通过野心和暴力实现了这一切，但也通过狡猾和某种冷静、精明的计算。他不是一个可爱的人，那是肯定的。但他不像科尔特斯那样滑头，也不像佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多那样嗜血。
And the weird thing about Pizarro, as historians so often say, is he lacks the sort of driving motivations of a lot of conquistadors. Which is the lust for gold, the desire to convert Christianity? Right. All through this series, right? There's been very little about Christian conversion. You know, we haven't had accounts of the Spanish destroying temples out of zeal or insisting that their collaborators become Christians.
关于皮萨罗奇怪的事情，正如历史学家经常说的那样，他缺乏许多征服者的那种驱动动机。也就是对黄金的渴望，皈依基督教的愿望？对。在整个系列中，对吧？关于基督教皈依的内容很少。你知道，我们没有西班牙人出于狂热摧毁寺庙或坚持他们的合作者成为基督徒的记录。
You've had kind of, you've had priests watching with interest as people bow towards the sun. Exactly. And Pizarra sets the tone for this. He appears to be generally pretty. uninterested in this kind of thing. The amazing thing is, for a man who's been driven by the pursuit of gold, he's very uninterested in spending it. So we're told he didn't like fine food, he didn't like fine wine, he doesn't like hunting particularly, he wears the same old clothes he's always worn. He spends his spare time just hanging around in his orange orchard that he's
你有一种，你有牧师饶有兴趣地看着人们向太阳鞠躬。正是如此。皮萨罗为这一点定下了基调。他似乎通常对这种事情相当不感兴趣。令人惊奇的是，对于一个被追求黄金所驱动的人来说，他对花钱非常不感兴趣。所以我们被告知他不喜欢精致的食物，不喜欢精致的葡萄酒，他特别不喜欢打猎，他穿着他一直穿的同样的旧衣服。他把业余时间花在闲逛他建造的橘子园里，
had built and basically playing quits for pennies with ordinary Spanish soldiers. So what has driven him all this time? What has made him tick? What has made him risk everything? Adventure, glory. I mean, obviously, he likes having the goal, but he doesn't particularly want to spend it. He doesn't want to live a luxurious life. We just do not know. I mean, whether it's the fault of the sources or whether it's a reflection of his personality, but he's a much less vivid character than Cortez, isn't he? Yes, absolutely. And I think, but I think that's exactly what he was like. I think there's something opaque, opaque, possibly even a bit dull. There's nothing especially likable.
基本上和普通的西班牙士兵玩硬币游戏。那么是什么一直驱动着他？是什么让他行动？是什么让他冒一切风险？冒险，荣耀。我的意思是，显然，他喜欢拥有目标，但他并不特别想花掉它。他不想过奢侈的生活。我们只是不知道。我的意思是，无论是来源的错误还是他个性的反映，但他是一个比科尔特斯不那么生动的角色，不是吗？是的，绝对。而且我认为，但我认为这就是他的样子。我认为有一种不透明，不透明，甚至可能有点沉闷。没有什么特别讨人喜欢的地方。
Although, actually, the other conquistadors generally did find him likable. They said he doesn't have, you know, he's not as untrustworthy as Cortez is. I mean, obviously, if you're Diego-Dar Magro, you might disagree. But by and large, he's neither lovable nor but especially loathsome by conquistador standards. He is, as you say, just dull. A bit vanilla. So, but in the summer of 1541, he hears some slightly worrying news. In Spain, his brother, Aernando, has been indicted.
不过，实际上，其他征服者通常还是觉得他挺讨人喜欢的。他们说他不像科尔特斯那样，你知道，没那么不可信。我的意思是，很明显，如果你是迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗，你可能会不同意。但总的来说，按照征服者的标准，他既不可爱，也不特别令人厌恶。正如你所说，他只是很无趣。有点平庸。所以，在1541年夏天，他听到了一些令人担忧的消息。在西班牙，他的兄弟埃尔南多被起诉了。
for the execution of Al-Magro. This is always the way with the Spaniards. And he's being held in the Al-Cathara, the castle in Madrid. And it's a reminder to Pizarro. You know, you can be very successful as a conquistador, but you never entirely secure.
因为处决了阿尔马格罗。西班牙人总是这样。他被关在马德里的阿尔卡萨城堡里。这对皮萨罗来说是一个提醒。你知道，作为一名征服者，你可以非常成功，但你永远无法完全高枕无忧。
And at the same time, he starts to hear rumors of unrest from the streets of Lima. Remember that Al-Magro had been the standard bearer for people who felt they'd arrived too late and they'd been left out
与此同时，他开始听到利马街头出现动荡的传言。记住，阿尔马格罗一直是那些觉得自己来得太晚、被遗忘的人的旗手。
and they hadn't shared in all the booty of the pizarros. And they feel resentful and frustrated and bitter. And people like that, who of course are arriving all the time, now have a new champion. And this is a young man who was born to a native woman in Panama and has arrived in Peru. And he's nicknamed El Moso, El Moso, the boy. But his real name is Diego de Al-Magro. He is the son of Pizarro's old rival. And in June 1541, the mayor of Lima says to Bizarro, this young man, you know, his father's son, you know, he's out for revenge, he's planning
他们没有分享到皮萨罗兄弟掠夺的所有战利品。他们感到怨恨、沮丧和痛苦。而像这样的人，当然一直在涌入，现在有了一位新的领袖。这是一个在巴拿马由当地妇女所生并来到秘鲁的年轻人。他的绰号是“埃尔·莫索”，即“男孩”。但他的真名是迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗。他是皮萨罗老对手的儿子。1541年6月，利马市长对皮萨罗说，这个年轻人，你知道，他父亲的儿子，他一心想报复，他正在策划
a coup to assassinate you at mass. And Bizarro says, what? In Lima, Lima's my city. I'm the big man. Nothing will happen. I don't have anything to fear from this boy. Then on Sunday the 26th June, that morning, he hears reports of trouble. People tell him that there are men outside Al Magro's house and they're shouting down with
一场政变，打算在弥撒时暗杀你。皮萨罗说，什么？在利马？利马是我的城市。我是这里的大人物。什么都不会发生。我没什么好怕这个男孩的。然后，在6月26日星期日那天早上，他听到了骚乱的报告。人们告诉他，阿尔马格罗的房子外面有人，他们在大喊打倒
the traitor, down with the tyrant, i.e. Pizarro. And he thinks, okay, well, to be on the safe side, I'll say that I'm ill and I won't go to Mass. And this afternoon, I'll go and get my cavalry. We'll ride into the city and we'll capture this little brat, and we will punish him. So the hour of mass comes, and Al Magro and his friends wait for Pizarra outside the cathedral. But obviously Pizarro doesn't come. They get one of their number, who's a Basque priest, and they say, go to Pizarro's house, found out what's going on. The priest goes to Pizarro's house and Pizarro very naively actually says to the priest
叛徒，打倒暴君，也就是皮萨罗。他想，好吧，为了保险起见，我就说我病了，不去参加弥撒了。今天下午，我会去召集我的骑兵。我们要骑马进城，抓住这个小混蛋，惩罚他。弥撒时间到了，阿尔马格罗和他的朋友们在教堂外等着皮萨罗。但显然皮萨罗没来。他们找了他们中的一个人，一个巴斯克神父，对他说，去皮萨罗家，看看发生了什么事。神父去了皮萨罗家，皮萨罗非常天真地对神父说
Oh come on him You know actually you can celebrate Mass here if you like So they start celebrating mass Meanwhile the other conspirators all pile down to Pizarro's house About 40 of them They start making a great racket outside the house banging on the door and shouting and stuff Pizarro sends one of his friends to find out what's going on
哦，进来吧。你知道，如果你愿意，你可以在这里主持弥撒。于是他们开始主持弥撒。与此同时，其他阴谋者都涌向皮萨罗的家，大约有40人。他们在房子外面制造了巨大的噪音，敲门大喊大叫。皮萨罗派了一个朋友去看看发生了什么事。
At about this point Pizarro's servants are indigenous people Like scrambling out of the windows and stuff This is absolutely insane Why is he so blithely oblivious to all this? Clearly these men mean us nothing but ill. And at this point, doors of Pizarro's mansion crash open and Al-Magro the Youngers men burst in. And Pizarro grabs a sword and a dagger
就在这时，皮萨罗的仆人，那些原住民，正从窗户爬出来之类的。这简直太疯狂了。为什么他对这一切如此漫不经心？显然这些人对我们没安好心。就在这时，皮萨罗宅邸的大门被撞开了，阿尔马格罗二世的人冲了进来。皮萨罗抓起一把剑和一把匕首，
and he stands there in the doorway. Remember, he's in his 60s. But the attackers are on him right away. He cuts the first one down, but the men behind him are too strong. They slash at Pizarro's body, and one of them stabs him in the throat, and he falls to the ground. and then one of the attackers Juan Borrigan wrote this account.
站在门口。记住，他已经60多岁了。但袭击者立刻围了上来。他砍倒了第一个人，但他身后的人太强了。他们砍向皮萨罗的身体，其中一人刺中了他的喉咙，他倒在了地上。然后袭击者之一胡安·德·巴里加写下了这段记录。
When the Marquis had fallen wounded to the ground, he made the sign of the cross over his mouth with his fingers and begged confession for his sins. But I took an urn that was full of water and smashed it down onto his crossed fingers, and I said to him, In hell! You will have to confess in hell. It was a big jar and it broke his face.
当侯爵受伤倒地时，他用手指在嘴上画了一个十字，祈求忏悔自己的罪孽。但我拿了一个装满水的瓮，猛地砸在他交叉的手指上，我对他说，下地狱吧！你得在地狱里忏悔。那是一个大罐子，砸碎了他的脸。
And with that great blow, the Marquis, breathed his last. So that night, Pizarro's mangled body is buried behind the cathedral. And that is the end of the man who masterminded the conquest of the Inca's. So with that, everything changes again. So now you have in Lima, Almagro the Younger. He's parading through the streets and is shouting that I am the new master of Peru. But you still have one Pizarro brother left in South America, that is Gonzá'A. Alo, who is in keto, he's going to want revenge. And of course, in his jungle there, you have Manco Inca, who is planning one last comeback. So, Dominic, would you say still all to play for?
随着那重重的一击，侯爵咽下了最后一口气。那天晚上，皮萨罗伤痕累累的尸体被埋在教堂后面。这就是策划征服印加帝国的那个人的人生终点。随之而来，一切又发生了变化。现在在利马，阿尔马格罗二世出现了。他在街上游行，大喊着我是秘鲁的新主人。但你在南美洲还剩下一个皮萨罗兄弟，那就是贡萨洛·皮萨罗，他在基多，他会想要报复。当然，在他所在的丛林里，还有曼科·印加，他正在策划最后一次反击。那么，多米尼克，你会说一切皆有可能吗？
Absolutely all to play for, Tom. Yeah. I mean, mad to stop listening now. Yeah, you'd be completely mad. So come back after the break for the thrilling final chapter of this epic and blood-soaked saga. This episode is brought to you by Vanguard. Now, Dominic history is full of examples of people who are promised the world and then got very badly let down. Can you think of a particular example? I can think of a couple of examples, Tom. So we've just been recording a series about the fall of the Incas. And Francisco Pizarro, who was the Spanish conquister or in charge, first of all, he betrayed his business partner, Diego de de Magro.
绝对一切皆有可能，汤姆。是的。我的意思是，现在停止收听就太疯狂了。是的，你完全疯了。所以休息之后回来，收听这部史诗般血腥传奇的激动人心的最后一章。本集由先锋领航（Vanguard）赞助。现在，多米尼克，历史上充满了被许诺全世界却最终被严重辜负的人的例子。你能想到一个具体的例子吗？我能想到几个例子，汤姆。我们刚刚录制了一个关于印加帝国灭亡的系列节目。而弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗，那位负责的西班牙征服者，首先，他背叛了他的商业伙伴迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗。
And then, shockingly, he betrayed the Inca Emperor at a well. Well, Dominic, can I ask you a question? Had Atta Walpa been in the hands of Vanguard, do you think that Vanguard would have let him down? No, the thing about Vanguard, Vanguard was founded on one core principle, and that principle is putting investors first. Tom, for more than 50 years, Vanguard have been delivering on that promise for millions of clients worldwide. And do you know what's brilliant? You too can open an ISA or a self-invested personal pension, and you can choose investments yourself, or you can let Vanguard choose and manage them for you. So search a Vanguard investor to find out more when investing your capital is
然后，令人震惊的是，他在阿塔瓦尔帕那里背叛了印加皇帝。好吧，多米尼克，我可以问你一个问题吗？如果阿塔瓦尔帕在先锋领航的手中，你认为先锋领航会辜负他吗？不，关于先锋领航，先锋领航建立在一个核心原则之上，那就是将投资者放在首位。汤姆，50多年来，先锋领航一直在为全球数百万客户兑现这一承诺。你知道什么最棒吗？你也可以开设个人储蓄账户（ISA）或个人养老金账户，你可以自己选择投资，或者让先锋领航为你选择和管理。所以搜索“先锋领航投资者”以了解更多信息，投资资本是有
at risk and tax rules apply. Hello and welcome back to the rest is history. So the two principal characters in our story, Pizarro and Almagro, the business partners who, whose relationship stretched right the way back to episode one, whose bloody vendetta has laid waste to Peru. They are both now dead. Their vendetta has cost both of them their lives. And I guess, Dominic, the big question is where does that leave the struggle for supremacy in Peru, which is by now war-ravaged, smallpox scarred, ransacked of gold and silver in a very, very poor way? Yes, exactly. So we've still got our two rival Inca emperors.
风险的，且适用税收规则。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。所以我们故事中的两个主要人物，皮萨罗和阿尔马格罗，这对商业伙伴，他们的关系一直追溯到第一集，他们血腥的仇杀摧毁了秘鲁。他们现在都死了。他们的仇杀让他们俩都付出了生命的代价。我想，多米尼克，最大的问题是，这让秘鲁的霸权之争处于什么境地？秘鲁现在已经饱受战争蹂躏，天花肆虐，金银被洗劫一空，处于非常非常糟糕的状态。是的，没错。所以我们仍然有两个敌对的印加皇帝。
We still have Powellu and Kusko with his lovely coat of arms that you think is a bit too garrish. It's busy. So he doesn't die horribly. He lives peacefully till about 1550 and then he dies of old age or illness in his bed. In his bed, I mean, unheard of. He has no legitimate children and the Spanish don't bother, you know, proclaiming a successor. By this point, the Inca Empire has been consigned to history, really.
我们仍然有在库斯科的保卢，他那可爱的纹章你觉得有点太俗气了。它太繁杂了。所以他没有死得很惨。他平静地生活到1550年左右，然后因年老或疾病在床上去世。在床上，我的意思是，闻所未闻。他没有合法的孩子，西班牙人也没有费心去宣布继任者。到这个时候，印加帝国真的已经成为历史了。
So they think, well, we don't even need a puppet. You know, who cares? Now, there's also Manco in Vilcabamba in the jungle. He's kept out of the civil wars. He's just watching, hoping they all lose, which they kind of are. So he's waiting. But people who enjoy confusing Spanish vendettas, will be pleased to hear that this particular one is actually not quite over
所以他们想，好吧，我们甚至不需要傀儡。你知道，谁在乎呢？现在，在丛林里的比尔卡班巴还有曼科。他避开了内战。他只是在观察，希望他们都输，而他们确实也快输了。所以他在等待。但是那些喜欢混乱的西班牙仇杀的人，会很高兴听到这个特定的仇杀实际上还没有完全结束，
because it simply moves to the next generation. So the Pizarro's champion is Gonzalo. Gonzalo, we described him in episode one. The Spanish chronic was saying handsome, popular, virtuous, easygoing. But he's behaved disgracefully throughout this series. That wasn't his vibe in the previous episode. Not at all. Now, he has been doing something very fun.
因为它只是转移到了下一代。所以皮萨罗的拥护者是贡萨洛。贡萨洛，我们在第一集里描述过他。西班牙编年史说他英俊、受欢迎、有美德、随和。但他在整个系列中表现得非常可耻。那不是他在上一集里的风格。一点也不。现在，他一直在做一些非常有趣的事情。
He has been searching for the mythical land of cinnamon in the Amazon. And he went there with a guy called Francisco de Oriana. And if you've ever seen one of our stage shows, particularly in Australia, you may remember that Oriana went all the way down the Amazon, didn't he? He met people who'd invented Wellington Boots or something. I can't remember all the details. And this is the first kind of real great quest for El Dorado, isn't it? Exactly.
他一直在亚马逊寻找神话中的肉桂之国。他和一个叫弗朗西斯科·德·奥雷利亚纳的人一起去了那里。如果你看过我们的舞台表演，特别是在澳大利亚的，你可能记得奥雷利亚纳一直沿着亚马逊河走，对吧？他遇到了发明了惠灵顿靴子之类东西的人。我不记得所有细节了。这是第一次真正伟大的寻找黄金国的探索，不是吗？没错。
Gonzalo went back to Quito, to the lilt of the Spanish guitar, and there he heard the news of his brother's death, and he took over leadership of the Pizarro clan. So he's there in Ecuador. The Almagristers, as they are called, are delighted with life now. They're in control of Lima under Almagro the Younger. And Almagro the Younger, who's just 22, says,
贡萨洛回到基多，伴随着西班牙吉他的旋律，在那里他听到了他兄弟去世的消息，并接管了皮萨罗家族的领导权。所以他在厄瓜多尔。阿尔马格罗派，正如他们所称的那样，现在对生活感到非常高兴。他们在阿尔马格罗二世的领导下控制了利马。而年仅22岁的阿尔马格罗二世说，
Well, I'm now the governor of New Castile. Brilliant, I've won. This does not go down well with Charles V. People aren't watching this in Spain and saying, well, this is actually tremendous behavior. Our conquistadors has behaved incredibly well. Charles V, who is a very, he's quite a boring man himself, isn't he, for one of the most powerful men who ever lived? Charles VIII gets these reports at his desk and says, they're just all murdering each other and proclaiming that they're the governor. I'm in charge of choosing the governor.
好吧，我现在是新卡斯蒂利亚的总督了。太棒了，我赢了。这在查理五世那里可不受欢迎。人们在西班牙看到这个并不会说，这真是了不起的行为。我们的征服者表现得非常好。查理五世，他自己本身就是一个非常无聊的人，不是吗？对于有史以来最强大的人之一来说？查理五世在他的办公桌上收到这些报告，说，他们只是在互相残杀，并宣称自己是总督。我是负责选择总督的人。
and he's already sent a special investigator to call Vaca de Castro to South America. I mean, that's a tough gig, isn't it? I think it's a terrible gig. I think it's actually a terrible gig. I mean, if you're a judge in Spain and you're...
而且他已经派了一名特别调查员，即瓦卡·德·卡斯特罗，前往南美洲。我的意思是，那是一项艰巨的任务，不是吗？我认为这是一项糟糕的任务。我认为这实际上是一项糟糕的任务。我的意思是，如果你是西班牙的一名法官，而你……
You've got to go and sort out between these two thuggish clans. Exactly. You definitely don't want to do that. Vacca de Castro gets to Peru and there he's told that Pizarre has been murdered. And Charles VIII had said to him, if something like that happens, you become the governor yourself and sort it out.
你必须去解决这两个暴徒家族之间的纠纷。没错。你绝对不想那样做。瓦卡·德·卡斯特罗到达秘鲁，在那里他被告知皮萨罗被谋杀了。查理五世曾对他说，如果发生这样的事，你自己就成为总督，把事情解决掉。
So Vacca de Castro does precisely that. He lands in Peru and he says this is absolutely intolerable. He raises the royal standard and he says, I'm out for blood against Almagro Jr. And they have a showdown outside what is now the city of Ayacucho in central Peru, the Battle of Chupas in September 1542. Now this is a much more modern battle than the one we had in the first half. So there's all kinds of archibuses, there's light artillery, it's sort of proper early modern stuff.
所以瓦卡·德·卡斯特罗正是这样做的。他降落在秘鲁，说这绝对是不可容忍的。他升起皇家旗帜，说，我要为阿尔马格罗二世复仇。他们在现在秘鲁中部的阿亚库乔市外进行了一场决战，即1542年9月的楚帕斯战役。这比我们在上半部分提到的那场战斗要现代得多。所以有各种各样的火绳枪，有轻型火炮，这算是正儿八经的近代战争了。
And crucially, pikes. And these pikes disembowel the horses. And I kind of, I guess, illustrate to the Inca's what they've been missing out on. Yeah, the Inkers didn't have pikes, and they thought only they had pikes, it would be a very different story. Now, one of the guys who dies at this battle,
而且至关重要的是，长矛。这些长矛刺穿了马匹。我想，这向印加人展示了他们错过了什么。是的，印加人没有长矛，他们认为如果只有他们有长矛，那将是一个完全不同的故事。现在，在这场战斗中死去的人之一，
is a familiar name to people who listen to the first part of the series. He's the Greek bloke, Pedro de Kandia from Crete. Yeah. Remember him? Yeah. So he had fired the artillery signal that marked the kidnapping of Atoll Welper. And then he'd gone off on a kind of proto-Eldorado quest, which had gone horribly wrong.
对于听过本系列第一部分的人来说是一个熟悉的名字。他是那个希腊人，来自克里特岛的佩德罗·德·坎迪亚。是的。记得他吗？是的。所以他发射了标志着绑架阿塔瓦尔帕的火炮信号。然后他去进行了一次类似原始黄金国的探索，结果出了大问题。
Exactly. And he's fighting in this battle for Almagro the Younger. And do you know who kills him? I mean, given the way the Spanish behave, people can probably anticipate. The guy who kills him is Almagro the Younger. He kills him for, and I quote, treachery in not firing his cannon sufficiently vigorously. You basically, you don't want to be involved in this business at all, I think. don't want to be involved with the young macro guys. They're terrible. The Royal Army under Vacca Castro wins a huge victory, and Vacca de Castro, he says, I'm going to lay down the law now, no prisoners.
没错。他在这场战斗中为阿尔马格罗二世而战。你知道是谁杀了他吗？考虑到西班牙人的行为方式，人们大概能预料到。杀他的人是阿尔马格罗二世。他杀他是因为，我引用一下，“背叛，没有足够有力地发射他的大炮”。你基本上根本不想卷入这桩生意，我想。不想和阿尔马格罗二世的人混在一起。他们太可怕了。瓦卡·德·卡斯特罗领导的皇家军队赢得了巨大的胜利，瓦卡·德·卡斯特罗说，我现在要制定法律，不留俘虏。
And we're told, the ditch under the scaffold was full of dead bodies. And then, brilliantly, this gave considerable pleasure to the native onlookers. I bet. Although they were amazed to think that many of the victims had been captains holding posts of honour. So again, huge spectator sport. Yeah, you've got to get your pleasures where you can. Exactly. you that. So Almagro Jr. gets away. He flees to Cusco with a friend of his called Diego
我们被告知，绞刑架下的沟里全是尸体。然后，精彩的是，这给当地的旁观者带来了相当大的乐趣。我敢打赌。尽管他们很惊讶地想到许多受害者都是担任荣誉职位的队长。所以，这又是一项巨大的观赏性运动。是的，你必须在能找到的地方寻找乐趣。没错。就是这样。所以阿尔马格罗二世逃脱了。他和一个叫迭戈的朋友逃到了库斯科。
Mendez. And their plan is actually, they'll head on from Cusco to take refuge with Manko, right? Another twist. Because Diego Mendes is clearly a bit of a dog because he dallies in Cusco for a final visit to his mistress. And that slows them down. They're overtaken in the valley by a posse from Cusco. And they're dragged back to Cusco. Mendez is imprisoned. Almagro Jr. is taken to the Central Square, he's tried for rebellion, he is unsurprisingly grotted, and then he's beheaded. So that is the definitive end of Al-Magro. Now this bloke Mendez, who'd been his pal, he ends up escaping. A team's set with six other fugitives from the Al-Magro faction.
门德斯。他们的计划实际上是，他们将从库斯科出发，去寻求曼科的庇护，对吧？又一个转折。因为迭戈·门德斯显然有点像条狗，因为他在库斯科逗留，最后一次去见他的情妇。这拖慢了他们的速度。他们在山谷中被库斯科派出的搜捕队追上了。他们被拖回了库斯科。门德斯被监禁。阿尔马格罗二世被带到中央广场，他因叛乱受审，不出所料地被绞死，然后被斩首。这就是阿尔马格罗的最终结局。现在这个叫门德斯的家伙，他曾经是他的伙伴，他最终逃脱了。他与阿尔马格罗派的其他六名逃亡者组成了一支队伍。
And they do manage to get over the mountains to Vilcabamba and to Manco. Now, some of Manco's captains, when these blokes turned up, they said, Oh, really, the Almagristas, you know, just kill them. Just get rid. These people are always trouble. And Manco, it's weird how everybody in this entire story at some point is guilty of crass naivety. Yeah, after 10 years of this mad backstabbing, they say, what could go wrong?
他们确实设法翻过山脉到达了比尔卡班巴，找到了曼科。现在，曼科的一些队长，当这些家伙出现时，他们说，哦，真的，阿尔马格罗派，你知道，杀了他们。除掉他们。这些人总是麻烦。而曼科，奇怪的是，这个故事里的每个人在某个时刻都犯了愚蠢的天真。是的，在经历了10年这种疯狂的背后捅刀子之后，他们说，能出什么错呢？
I'm trusted. They seem nice. Manco says, well, they can teach us to ride horses and to fire their Spanish weapons. So he puts them up in his so-called palace in Viccos. This is the sort of courtyards on a promontory overlooking the valley. And Titou Cousie, Manco's son says, My father ordered they should have houses in which to live. He ordered his own women to prepare their food and drink.
我相信他们。他们看起来不错。曼科说，好吧，他们可以教我们骑马和发射他们的西班牙武器。所以他把他们安置在他所谓的维科斯宫殿里。这是那种俯瞰山谷的岬角上的庭院。曼科的儿子蒂托·库西说，我父亲命令他们应该有房子住。他命令他自己的女人为他们准备食物和饮料。
He took his meals with them. He treated them as if they were his own brothers. So with that, I think our listeners can guess what's coming. So two years later, these are Magrista refugees get a secret message from Cusco. Basically, the new authorities in Peru will forgive you if you can murder Manco. And they discuss this, and one of their female servants hears them discussing it. And the servant tells Manco's commanders, and they tell Manco. And Manco again, he just says, no, I don't believe they would do this.
他和他们一起吃饭。他对待他们就像对待自己的兄弟一样。所以，我想我们的听众可以猜到接下来会发生什么。两年后，这些阿尔马格罗派的难民从库斯科收到了一条秘密信息。基本上，秘鲁的新当局会原谅你，如果你能谋杀曼科的话。他们讨论了这件事，他们的一名女仆听到了他们的讨论。仆人告诉了曼科的指挥官，他们告诉了曼科。而曼科又一次，他只是说，不，我不相信他们会这样做。
He says, I think you've made this up. I think you've actually made this up, because you want me to get rid of these Spaniards so that you can have their weapons for yourself. I'm not going to fall for that one. My guests will never betray me in this way. And then what happens next? Insane. And this is an account by a guy called Juan de Betanzos. He says, they decided to have a game of quoits.
他说，我想你们是编造的。我想你们实际上是编造的，因为你们想让我除掉这些西班牙人，这样你们就可以自己得到他们的武器。我不会上那个当的。我的客人永远不会以这种方式背叛我。然后接下来发生了什么？太疯狂了。这是一个叫胡安·德·贝坦索斯的人的记录。他说，他们决定玩一种投掷游戏。
They hoped the Inca would wish to play with them at this game, as he usually did. This has my single favorite detail, by the way, from the whole series. Then, while playing, they would concoct a quarrel with him and gang up to kill him. They hid daggers in their boots. They hid many bread rolls up their sleeves to eat in the jungle when they... I think that's a massive giveaway, frankly. If a bloke turns up and his sleeves and stuff with bread rolls,
他们希望印加人能像往常一样和他们一起玩这个游戏。顺便说一句，这是我整个系列中最喜欢的细节。然后，在玩的时候，他们会编造一个争吵，联合起来杀了他。他们把匕首藏在靴子里。他们把许多面包卷藏在袖子里，以便在丛林里吃，当他们……我认为这坦率地说是一个巨大的泄密。如果一个家伙出现，他的袖子里塞满了面包卷，
you know you're in trouble. They start playing this game. They part of being quoits. It's basically throwing horseshoes. Manko says, I don't want to play. I'm not in the mood. I'd all say, why have you got all those bread rolls off his sleeves? What's going on here?
你知道你有麻烦了。他们开始玩这个游戏。他们玩的是投掷游戏。基本上就是扔马蹄铁。曼科说，我不想玩。我没心情。他们都说，你为什么袖子里有那么多面包卷？这是怎么回事？
I mean, why someone like the Cohen brothers haven't made a film of this? I do not know. Anyway, they start playing the coits. They feign having an argument over at a fact. foul throw, Manco moves into referee. And then one of them, Gomez Perez, took out his dagger and plunged it into the Inca's chest. And the terrible thing is that one of the people watching this is Manco's son Tito Kusi, who was nine years old, and who wrote this, or dictated, this very evocative account to what followed. My father, feeling himself wounded, tried to defend
我的意思是，为什么像科恩兄弟这样的人没有拍一部关于这个的电影？我不知道。无论如何，他们开始玩投掷游戏。他们假装因为一个犯规投掷而争吵，曼科走过去当裁判。然后其中一个人，戈麦斯·佩雷斯，掏出匕首刺进了印加人的胸膛。可怕的是，观看这一幕的人之一是曼科的儿子蒂托·库西，他当时九岁，他写下了，或者口述了，这段非常生动的记录，记录了接下来发生的事情。我父亲，感到自己受伤了，试图保护
himself, but he was alone and unarmed, and there were seven of them with knives. He fell to the ground covered with wounds and they left him for dead. I was only a small boy, but seeing my father hurt, I wanted to go and help him. But they turned furiously upon me and hurled a spear which only just missed me. I was terrified and hid among some bushes. They searched for me, but failed to find me. And maybe you'll know this better than me, but I can't think of many accounts from the 16th century or earlier of something like this that are quite as personal, you know, by somebody's son telling the story firsthand about the terror and the horror of that kind of moment. Is he writing this in Spanish?
自己，但他孤身一人，手无寸铁，而他们有七个人拿着刀。他倒在地上，浑身是伤，他们以为他死了。我还是个小男孩，但看到父亲受伤，我想去帮他。但他们愤怒地转向我，投掷了一支长矛，只差一点就击中了我。我吓坏了，躲在灌木丛中。他们搜寻我，但没能找到我。也许你比我更了解这一点，但我无法想到16世纪或更早时期有太多像这样个人化的记录，你知道，由某人的儿子亲口讲述关于那一刻的恐惧和恐怖的故事。他是用西班牙语写的吗？
He's dictating it to a missionary, to a Spanish missionary who wrote it all down. So basically we have Tito Kuzzi's account of the entire conquest, given, dictated by him to Spaniards who came to visit him later on. It gives you a sense of if that is the kind of standard for Incan narrative. Yeah. How badly we've missed out on not having other such eyewitnesses. Just a very straightforward kind of account. I mean, what he doesn't mention is whether they had bread rolls falling out of their sleeves as this happened.
他是口述给一位传教士，一位西班牙传教士，他把这一切都写了下来。所以基本上我们有蒂托·库西关于整个征服过程的记录，由他口述给后来来看望他的西班牙人。这让你感觉到，如果这就是印加叙事的标准。是的。我们错过了没有其他这样的目击者是多么可惜。只是一个非常直接的记录。我的意思是，他没有提到当这一切发生时，他们的袖子里是否有面包卷掉出来。
Well, he was very young, wasn't he? Maybe he thought that was standard for a Spaniard. Yeah. Well, they could have been doing it for weeks before to lull him into a false and security. That's proper planning, isn't it? Yeah. It's sort of secreting tapas around their place. Bocados.
嗯，他当时很小，不是吗？也许他认为这对西班牙人来说是标准的。是的。好吧，他们可能在几周前就开始这样做，以让他陷入虚假的安全感。那是真正的计划，不是吗？是的。这就像在他们的地方藏匿小吃。塔帕斯。
Yeah. So anyway, these guys, they run into the jungle. I mean, this is a stupid plan. The Coits and all that. How they thought they could get away with this, I do not know. They're chasing to the jungle by Manco is. bodyguards. They end up being cornered in a thatched hut, rather like John Wilkes' booth. So loads of Inca's appear outside, Boston Corbett style. They pile up wood, they set it on fire,
是的。所以无论如何，这些人，他们跑进了丛林。我的意思是，这是一个愚蠢的计划。投掷游戏和所有这些。他们怎么认为他们能逃脱惩罚，我不知道。他们被曼科的保镖追进了丛林。他们最终被困在一个茅草屋里，很像约翰·威尔克斯·布斯。所以大量的印加人出现在外面，波士顿科比特风格。他们堆起木头，放火点燃，
any of the Hispanians that come out shot with arrows, and the rest are all burned alive. And that's the end of the assassins. And sadly, the end of poor Manco. So he was embalmed, he was taken down the hill to Vilcabamba, and he was housed in the temple of the sun there. And actually, most Spanish sources were very damning about his murder. They didn't see his assassins as heroes. They saw them as cold-blooded traitors. And actually, most of the Spanish sources saw Manco was pretty admirable. You know, a noble adversary.
任何出来的西班牙人都被箭射死，其余的人都被活活烧死。这就是刺客的结局。可悲的是，也是可怜的曼科的结局。所以他被防腐处理，被带下山到比尔卡班巴，并被安置在那里的太阳神庙中。实际上，大多数西班牙资料对他的谋杀都非常谴责。他们没有把他的刺客视为英雄。他们把他们视为冷血的叛徒。实际上，大多数西班牙资料都认为曼科相当令人钦佩。你知道，一个高尚的对手。
And historians have been very kind to him by and large. Clearly, he was a, you know, he was a resilient and courageous man who inspired people to stick with him and not to collaborate. John Heming calls him an indomitable patriot. the only native prince whose royal lineage and stubborn courage enjoyed the respect of Spaniards and Indians alike. And I have to say he's probably one of the very few admirable characters from this entire series. With Manco's death, any chance of a serious native fightback pretty much disappears. So we're now 1544, 12 years after Bizarre's arrival. And the Spanish supremacy is largely unchallenged. So most of the land now of the former Inca Empire is devourable
历史学家总的来说对他非常友善。显然，他是一个，你知道，他是一个坚韧而勇敢的人，激励人们坚持跟随他，而不是合作。约翰·赫明称他为不屈不挠的爱国者。唯一一位其皇室血统和顽强勇气受到西班牙人和印第安人共同尊重的本土王子。我必须说，他可能是整个系列中极少数令人钦佩的人物之一。随着曼科的去世，任何严重的本土反击机会几乎都消失了。所以我们现在是1544年，皮萨罗到达12年后。西班牙的霸权在很大程度上是不可挑战的。所以前印加帝国的大部分土地现在可以被
between about 500 Spanish landowners. They built these large stone mansions in Spanish colonial settlements, places like Lima or Trujillo, which is also on the coast, full of hangers-on. They import European horses, they import African slaves and Spanish women to be their wives. Gold has by now pretty much all gone. It's gone back to Europe. So these guys live on proceeds from their massive estates there in Comiendas. Now there are people arriving all the time from Spain at this point. You know, hundreds of people who don't have gold and who don't get estates. And they are very impatient and resentful and they take it out on the locals. And the reports back to Spain that the rabble, as they are called, are behaving very badly. They're taking local
大约500名西班牙地主瓜分。他们在西班牙殖民定居点建造了这些大型石宅，像利马或特鲁希略这样的地方，也在海岸上，到处都是随从。他们进口欧洲马匹，进口非洲奴隶和西班牙妇女作为他们的妻子。黄金到目前为止几乎全部消失了。它已经回到了欧洲。所以这些人靠他们在恩科米恩达（Encomiendas）的大庄园的收益生活。现在此时此刻，人们一直在从西班牙涌入。你知道，成百上千没有黄金、也没有得到庄园的人。他们非常不耐烦和怨恨，他们把气撒在当地人身上。回到西班牙的报告说，这些所谓的暴民表现得非常糟糕。他们把当地
people as slaves and all of this kind of thing. And this is the context in company with the protests of clergymen like Las Casas, who you mentioned before. Who is now on the Royal Council by this point. Exactly. So this is the context of what are called the new laws of the early 15th 40s. So this is Charles V, responding to these complaints. And he says, no more abuses. Stop giving out indigenous people's land and giving out indigenous people themselves as workforce. Our colonial officials, it should be a priority for them to look after, in averted commas, Indian welfare. We should treat them as equal subjects of the Spanish crown, you know, basically be a bit kinder. And specifically no slavery. So neither because of war, even under the category of rebellion, nor by
人当作奴隶，所有这些事情。这就是背景，伴随着像拉斯·卡萨斯这样的神职人员的抗议，你之前提到过。他此时已经在皇家委员会了。没错。所以这就是所谓的1540年代初“新法”的背景。所以这是查理五世在回应这些投诉。他说，不再有虐待了。停止分发原住民的土地，停止把原住民本身当作劳动力。我们的殖民官员，照顾，用引号括起来，“印第安人的福利”应该是他们的优先事项。我们应该把他们视为西班牙王室的平等臣民，你知道，基本上要友善一点。特别是禁止奴隶制。所以无论是由于战争，即使是在叛乱的类别下，还是通过
Barton, nor for any other cause in any other way, may any Indian be made a slave. Exactly. At the time, lots of sort of churchmen said, great, this is exactly what we want. Historians, of course, think very highly of the new laws because they're a step in a more liberal direction. But at the time, Spanish settlers in the Americas hated them. They were outraged. The things were heard by the people over here with great indignation. There was a wild tumult with the news flying from one part to another. So go woke and go broke. Right, well, this is what happens. Because Charles sends a viceroy to enforce the new laws in Peru in 1544, the settlers go ballistic and their champion is a very familiar name. It is none other than Gonzalo Pizarro. He's now in his mid-30s and he thinks, finally, this is the chance to make myself the unchallenged strongman of Peru. He raises an army and he says, I'm going to use this against Vilcabamba, against the Inca, the Linka kingdom. But actually, once he's raised it, he uses it to march on Lima.
易货，还是因为任何其他原因，以任何其他方式，任何印第安人都不得被沦为奴隶。没错。当时，许多神职人员说，太好了，这正是我们想要的。历史学家当然对“新法”评价很高，因为它们是向更自由方向迈出的一步。但在当时，美洲的西班牙定居者讨厌它们。他们感到愤怒。这些事情被这里的人们听到时非常愤慨。随着消息从一个地方传到另一个地方，出现了一场疯狂的骚乱。所以“觉醒”就会破产。好吧，这就是发生的事情。因为查理在1544年派了一位总督去秘鲁执行“新法”，定居者们变得歇斯底里，他们的领袖是一个非常熟悉的名字。正是贡萨洛·皮萨罗。他现在30多岁，他想，终于，这是让我成为秘鲁不可挑战的强人的机会。他组建了一支军队，他说，我要用它来对付比尔卡班巴，对付印加，印加王国。但实际上，一旦他组建了它，他就用它向利马进军。
And this is such an interesting moment. In his book, John Hemming points out that this is basically a preview of so many rebellions in the Americas over the next few centuries. Except that I guess that particularly in South America, the rhetoric will be that this is a campaign launched in aid of liberty from servitude. Liberty from the oppression of the crown. But Pizarro is essentially doing this because he wants to restore servitude. Well, for other people. Which is also, of course, I guess, what the founding fathers also. Wait, we're about to get on to this.
这是一个非常有趣的时刻。在他的书中，约翰·赫明指出，这基本上是未来几个世纪美洲许多叛乱的预演。除了我猜，特别是在南美洲，修辞将是这是一场为了从奴役中获得自由而发起的运动。从王室的压迫中获得自由。但皮萨罗本质上这样做是因为他想恢复奴役。好吧，为其他人。这也是，我猜，开国元勋们也……等等，我们正要谈到这个。
John Hemming, a home government had legislated too liberally on behalf of colonial natives. The colonists loudly protested their loyalty to Crown and mother country, but demanded a free hand to exploit the territory that they had won and settled. So, in other words, Tom, this is a dry run for the tax revolt. of the 1770s. And there is only one major difference between Gonzalo Pizarro and George Washington. And you know what that difference is? Gonzalo Pizarro had... He had his own teeth. He had all his own teeth. He did not walk around with somebody with slaves' teeth in his mouth. Also, Gonzalo Pizarro was a massive hypocrite. So that's another big difference. And you know someone else who had that perspective on the revolution in America?
约翰·赫明，本国政府在殖民地原住民方面立法过于自由。殖民者大声抗议他们对王室和祖国的忠诚，但要求自由地剥削他们赢得和定居的领土。所以，换句话说，汤姆，这是1770年代税收反抗的预演。贡萨洛·皮萨罗和乔治·华盛顿之间只有一个主要区别。你知道那个区别是什么吗？贡萨洛·皮萨罗有……他有自己的牙齿。他有他自己所有的牙齿。他没有带着别人的奴隶的牙齿在嘴里走来走去。此外，贡萨洛·皮萨罗是一个巨大的伪君子。所以那是另一个巨大的区别。你知道还有谁对美国的革命有那种看法吗？
It's Dr. Johnson. It's Dr. Johnson, who will be appearing in our next series. Brilliant. So it all links up. Because people at this point are thinking, well, enough of this. I want to hear about this Dr. Johnson guy. He sounds very sound. And as luck would have it, he'll be joining us on Monday. So, Gonzalo Pizarro, the George Washington of Peru.
是约翰逊博士。是约翰逊博士，他将出现在我们的下一个系列中。太棒了。所以这一切都联系在一起了。因为人们此时在想，好吧，受够了。我想听听这个约翰逊博士的家伙。他听起来很靠谱。正如运气所愿，他将在周一加入我们。所以，贡萨洛·皮萨罗，秘鲁的乔治·华盛顿。
He kills the viceroy and he marches into Lima as the master of Peru. We're told he was wearing a sumptuous outfit. It's always good to hear about the clothes. A sumptuous outfit of black velvet, gold, plumes and jewels. I mean, to be fair, George Washington, that's not his style. That's not his vibe at all. However, Gonzalo by doing this basically is an open rebellion against the king of Spain. As we know from the American business, you know, once you've done that, you either have to go the whole way or not.
他杀死了总督，并作为秘鲁的主人进入了利马。我们被告知他穿着一套华丽的服装。听到关于衣服的事情总是很好。一套黑色天鹅绒、黄金、羽毛和珠宝的华丽服装。我的意思是，公平地说，乔治·华盛顿，那不是他的风格。那根本不是他的氛围。然而，贡萨洛通过这样做基本上是对西班牙国王的公开叛乱。正如我们从美国的事情中知道的那样，你知道，一旦你做了那个，你要么必须走到底，要么不走。
There's no real halfway house. Charles V sends a new viceroy called Pedro de Lagascar. And this says to this new viceroy, right, okay, scrap the woke laws. That hasn't worked at all. You know, as you said, Tom, we've been too liberal. Forget all that. However, we have to punish Gonzalo. You cannot, you know, rebel against the crown and kill the viceroy.
没有真正的中间地带。查理五世派了一位名叫佩德罗·德·拉加斯卡的新总督。并对这位新总督说，好吧，废除那些“觉醒”的法律。那根本没用。你知道，正如你所说的，汤姆，我们太自由了。忘了所有那些。然而，我们必须惩罚贡萨洛。你不能，你知道，反抗王室并杀死总督。
So Gonzalo confronts the viceroy outside Cusco at a place called Jackie Hwana. But Gonzalo's men completely let him down, they all desert, and he has taken prisoner. And he has one last final confrontation. This guy who's behaved consistently badly, I think, from episode one to episode six. Gasca says to him, you'd be very ungrateful to his majesty. You pizarroes were nothing until he raised you from the dust and made you rich men. And Gonzalo, perhaps not entirely unfairly, says, What we did, we did at our own expense.
所以贡萨洛在库斯科外一个叫哈基瓦纳的地方与总督对峙。但贡萨洛的人完全辜负了他，他们都逃跑了，他被俘虏了。他进行了最后一次对峙。这个从第一集到第六集表现一直很糟糕的家伙，我想。加斯卡对他说，你对陛下非常忘恩负义。你们皮萨罗家族什么都不是，直到他把你从尘土中提拔起来，让你成为富人。而贡萨洛，也许并不完全不公平地说，我们所做的，是我们自费做的。
His Majesty did not lift us from the dust. The pizarros have been gentlemen since the Goths came to Spain. That's a good line. If we were poor, well, that explains why we went out to win this empire, and we gave it to His Majesty, that we might have kept it for ourselves. Do you know what he reminds me of a little bit there? Lope de Aguirre.
陛下并没有把我们从尘土中提拔起来。皮萨罗家族自哥特人来到西班牙以来就是绅士。那是一句好台词。如果我们很穷，好吧，这就解释了为什么我们出去赢得这个帝国，我们把它给了陛下，我们本可以把它留给自己。你知道他让我想起了一点什么吗？洛佩·德·阿吉雷。
Do you not think there's a sort of the resentment of giving everything away to the crown and all that kind of thing. Yeah, I mean, you can definitely see where Greery, the wrath of God comes from. I mean, and not least with all the garottings. Exactly, it's the same thing. So between Lopé de Geera, the madman,
你不觉得有一种把一切都交给王室的那种怨恨吗？是的，我的意思是，你绝对可以看出阿吉雷，上帝的愤怒，是从哪里来的。我的意思是，尤其是所有的绞刑。没错，是一回事。所以介于洛佩·德·阿吉雷，那个疯子，
Gonzalo de Pizarro and George Washington, I mean, they've got a lot in common, those three men. That's a dinner party I don't want to go to. Because George Washington would actually bore you to death before the other's got a chance to garot you. He'd cheer you his garden, wouldn't he?
贡萨洛·德·皮萨罗和乔治·华盛顿，我的意思是，那三个人有很多共同点。那是我不想参加的晚宴。因为乔治·华盛顿实际上会在其他人有机会绞死你之前让你无聊死。他会向你炫耀他的花园，不是吗？
So Gonzalo ends up being executed in the main square of Cusco, textbook execution, confesses his sins, apologises to the king, all of this. And that's the end of him. And that basically is the end of all of them. They've all died violently. After all that, the only exception is Anando Pizarro. He was in prison, if you remember, in Madrid. He ended up being moved to another prison and he stayed there for 20 years. He was released in 1561. And then he died 17 years later, aged about 74. Was he able to enjoy his
所以贡萨洛最终在库斯科的主广场被处决，教科书式的处决，忏悔他的罪孽，向国王道歉，所有这些。这就是他的结局。这基本上是他们所有人的结局。他们都死得很惨。在那之后，唯一的例外是埃尔南多·皮萨罗。如果你还记得，他被关在马德里的监狱里。他最终被转移到另一所监狱，在那里呆了20年。他于1561年获释。然后他在17年后去世，享年约74岁。他能享受他的
wealth. I don't think so really. I think a lot of it was probably confiscated and stuff. So it was all for nothing. Let's talk about what it was, what it all meant for the people that have been slightly absent for this series, which is basically the people of the Andean region. So a guy who've quoted a lot, John Hemming, brilliant, brilliant book on the conquest of the Inkers. Really, I can't recommend it too highly. He's very frank about what all this meant for the people of Ecuador, Peru and Bolivia, a total and utter demographic disaster. There are all kinds of accounts, including from that bloke I played on stage, Bithente de Valvarde, writing to Charles V in 1539.
财富吗？我不这么认为。我想大部分可能都被没收了之类的。所以这一切都是徒劳的。让我们谈谈它是什么，它对这个系列中稍微缺席的人意味着什么，也就是基本上安第斯地区的人民。所以一个我们引用了很多的人，约翰·赫明，精彩的，关于征服印加人的精彩书籍。真的，我怎么推荐都不为过。他非常坦率地谈到了这一切对厄瓜多尔、秘鲁和玻利维亚人民意味着什么，一场彻底的、完全的人口灾难。有各种各样的记录，包括我曾在舞台上扮演的那个家伙，比森特·德·瓦尔韦德，在1539年写给查理五世的信。
I moved across a good portion of this land and saw terrible destruction in it. Having seen the land before, I could not help feeling great sadness. The sight of such desolation would move anyone to great pity. I mean, we don't need to go into all the sort of evidence and the quotations, but other Spanish writers describe how towns and villages are deserted, populations, valleys where there were 40,000 people,
我走过了这片土地的很大一部分，看到了其中的可怕破坏。曾经见过这片土地，我不禁感到巨大的悲伤。看到这样的荒凉会使任何人感到巨大的怜悯。我的意思是，我们不需要深入探讨所有的证据和引文，但其他西班牙作家描述了城镇和村庄是如何荒废的，人口，曾经有4万人的山谷，
there are now 4,000 people. I mean, the key writer on this, again, is Las Casas, isn't it? Who, in 1552, he writes this book, the brief account of the destruction of the Indies, in which Peru features very prominently. And he casts it as a kind of genocidal destruction of a paradise. And he casts the Inca's as childlike, as peaceable, as never having committed any crime at all. And that is the narrative that then passes into Protestant countries and which Peter Schaffer, for instance, ends up inheriting, and which I think is still very much part of the narrative in, say, English-speaking countries. Completely.
现在只有4000人。我的意思是，关于这个的关键作家，再次是拉斯·卡萨斯，不是吗？他在1552年写了这本书，《西印度群岛毁灭简述》，其中秘鲁占有非常突出的地位。他把它描绘成一种对天堂的种族灭绝式的破坏。他把印加人描绘成孩子气的、和平的、从未犯过任何罪行的人。这就是后来传到新教国家的叙事，也是彼得·谢弗，例如，最终继承的叙事，我认为这仍然在，比如说，英语国家中是非常重要的一部分。完全是。
And it's part of that world, that sort of vibe of the panpipes are playing, native spirituality, in touch with nature, peaceful people, lovely textiles, all of that kind of thing. that there's not the degree of truth in that but as we established in episode one to be ruled by the Inkers was definitely not a barrel of laughs I mean they are pretty brutal you know they will deport you they will deny you private property they believe in forced labour
这是那个世界的一部分，那种排箫在演奏、本土灵性、与自然接触、和平的人民、可爱的纺织品，所有这些东西的氛围。那里面确实有一定程度的真实性，但正如我们在第一集中确立的那样，被印加人统治绝对不是一件开心的事。我的意思是，他们相当残忍，你知道，他们会驱逐你，他们会剥夺你的私有财产，他们相信强迫劳动，
you know massive chain gangs all of this kind of thing I'm not saying they're complete monsters but they're not saints either but also just really important to emphasise that we know about the monstrous of the conquistadors thanks to Spanish writers and Spanish moralists. And so that tension in attitudes to what the Europeans are doing in the Americas is there right from the beginning. It is not a kind of something specific to the 21st century to worry about this. No. I mean, just by the way, use the word or you mentioned genocide and that's something the historians talk about
你知道大规模的苦役犯之类的东西。我不是说他们是完全的怪物，但他们也不是圣人。但同样非常重要的是要强调，我们知道征服者的残暴多亏了西班牙作家和西班牙道德家。所以那种对欧洲人在美洲所作所为的态度上的紧张关系从一开始就存在。这不是21世纪才需要担心的事情。不。我的意思是，顺便说一句，使用这个词，或者你提到了种族灭绝，那是历史学家谈论的事情。
a lot. I think it's not right to call this a genocide for this reason. But that's Las Casas is rhetoric. I mean, Las Casas is providing these terms and these frames of reference. Of course. And lots of people today, if you Google it online, there are lots of people who will bandy around terms like these, which I think are wrong because most people probably died, not because of Spanish violence, but because of disease, by smallpox and measles.
很多。我认为因为这个原因称其为种族灭绝是不对的。但那是拉斯·卡萨斯的修辞。我的意思是，拉斯·卡萨斯提供了这些术语和参考框架。当然。今天很多人，如果你在网上搜索一下，会有很多人随口使用这些术语，我认为这是错误的，因为大多数人可能不是死于西班牙人的暴力，而是死于疾病，死于天花和麻疹。
We've already described the effect that they had in the Caribbean and in Meso, America, Central America and Mexico. The conquest, of course, follows the Civil War. Yes, the Civil War is just as bad, right? Yeah. Between them, the two of them destroyed Inca infrastructure, So the irrigation canals, the terraces, the roads, on which the economy depended. As early as 1539, some Spanish writers are saying, you know, because basically armies are criss-crossing the lamb taking people's food, people have nothing to eat. And as in the Caribbean, I think you have a massive sense of trauma and therefore a collapse in the birth rate.
我们已经描述了它们在加勒比海、中美洲和墨西哥造成的影响。征服当然紧随内战之后。是的，内战同样糟糕，对吧？是的。它们两者之间摧毁了印加的基础设施，也就是灌溉渠、梯田、道路，这些是经济赖以生存的基础。早在1539年，一些西班牙作家就说，你知道，因为军队基本上在横穿这片土地抢夺人们的食物，人们没有东西吃。就像在加勒比海一样，我认为你有一种巨大的创伤感，因此出生率出现了崩溃。
Of all people, Philip II of Spain wrote years later to the Archbishop of Lima. We have been informed that many people hang themselves. Others allow themselves to die by not eating. Others take poisoned herbs and mothers kill their babies at birth, saying they do it to free them from the hardships they suffer themselves. And that really reminds me of what people were saying about the Taino people in the Caribbean in the 1510s. There's this kind of cultural collapse which comes from the effect of colonisation. And if you survive, your life is not much fun.
西班牙的腓力二世在多年后写信给利马大主教，他写道：我们获悉许多人上吊自杀。其他人通过绝食让自己死去。还有人服用毒草，母亲们在婴儿出生时就杀掉他们，说她们这样做是为了让他们免受她们自己所遭受的苦难。这真的让我想起1510年代人们在加勒比海谈论泰诺人时所说的话。这是一种源于殖民化影响的文化崩溃。如果你幸存下来，你的生活也不会有什么乐趣。
So the survivors, because of the Encommiander system, are subject to punishing work requirements. So about four out of five men in Spanish ruled Peru in the 16th century are subject to forced labour. And as you said Tom, and I think you're dead right to make this point, the criticism does not come from without, it comes from within from Spanish, people, you know, senior Spanish officials. So this is a guy called Fernando de Santillan, who is a royal official in Peru and Ecuador in the 1560s. I think it's really telling quotation. He says, when people are healthy, they work only for tribute, even when they're sick they're forced to pay their tribute in full. They have nothing left over for themselves.
所以幸存者们，因为“监护征赋制”（Encomienda），受到惩罚性的工作要求。因此，16世纪西班牙统治下的秘鲁，大约五分之四的男性受到强迫劳动。正如你所说的汤姆，我认为你提出这一点非常正确，批评并非来自外部，而是来自内部，来自西班牙人，你知道，来自西班牙的高级官员。这是一个叫费尔南多·德·桑蒂兰的人，他是16世纪60年代秘鲁和厄瓜多尔的皇家官员。我认为这是一段非常有说服力的引文。他说，当人们健康时，他们只为贡赋而工作，即使在生病时，他们也被迫全额缴纳贡赋。他们自己什么都不剩了。
They're deeply depressed by their misery and servitude and they believe they must continue to work for the Spaniards for as long as they live. This is a Spaniard talking. Because of this they despair. They ask only for their daily bread and they cannot even have that. There are no people on earth so hardworking, humble or well behaved, but they live the most wretched and miserable lives of any people on earth. And actually, do you know what? The people he's talking about, the people in the fields, they don't even have the worst of it. The worst of it are the people who end up working in the mines, particularly the mine we mentioned before. The giant mine at Potosi in Bolivia, that opened in 1545. Tens of thousands of people were drafted there year after year to work as forced laborers digging out
他们因贫困和奴役而深感沮丧，他们认为只要活着就必须继续为西班牙人工作。这是一个西班牙人在说话。正因为如此，他们感到绝望。他们只求每日的面包，却连这都得不到。世上没有比他们更勤劳、谦逊或守规矩的人了，但他们却过着世上最悲惨、最凄凉的生活。而且，你知道吗？他所谈论的那些人，那些在田里干活的人，甚至还不是最惨的。最惨的是那些最终在矿井里工作的人，特别是我们之前提到的那个矿。1545年开采的玻利维亚波托西巨型矿。成千上万的人年复一年地被征召到那里，作为强迫劳工挖掘
silver. It ended up being called the mountain that eats men. And if you, you know, demographers, historians argue about exactly how many people died in that mine at such. Serra rica in Potosi. I mean, the highest estimate is 8 million people. The lower estimates are still hundreds of thousands of people died in these mines. I mean, just unbelievable. And the amount of silver produced from that will massively destabilise, not just the economy of Spain, not just the economy of Europe, but the entire global economy. And you can start to, you can start talking about the global economy. You can. Thanks to this. Thanks to this. The Silver is being shipped across to Spain.
白银。它最终被称为“吃人的山”。如果你，你知道，人口学家、历史学家争论到底有多少人死在那座矿里。波托西的塞拉里卡（Serra Rica）。我的意思是，最高的估计是800万人。较低的估计也有几十万人死在这些矿里。我的意思是，简直令人难以置信。由此产生的白银数量将极大地破坏不仅是西班牙的经济，不仅是欧洲的经济，而是整个全球经济。你可以开始，你可以开始谈论全球经济了。你可以。多亏了这个。多亏了这个。白银正被运往西班牙。
And as you say, the effects are rippling all through the world economy. It's a brilliant book on this by Charles C-Man called 1493, about the world after the discovery of the Americas. So we'll just finish off by telling you what happened to the jungle kingdom of Vilcabamba. Manco was succeeded by his son, who was called Sari Tupac, who was five years old. And he ruled in Vilcabamba for the next few years. They just kept themselves to themselves. They were very quiet. we're talking about maybe a couple of thousand people in the jungle.
正如你所说，其影响波及整个世界经济。查尔斯·曼恩写了一本关于此的精彩著作，名为《1493》，讲述了美洲被发现后的世界。所以我们最后讲讲比尔卡班巴丛林王国发生了什么。曼科之后由他的儿子继位，名叫萨里·图帕克，当时五岁。他在比尔卡班巴统治了接下来的几年。他们只是保持低调。他们非常安静。我们谈论的是丛林里可能只有几千人。
In 1552, Cyri Tupac, who was then late teens, got a letter from again, of all people, Philip II of Spain. He wasn't quite Philip II then. He was a prince. But Philip said to him, listen, I know that your father Manco was provoked into his uprising. Isn't it amazing, by the way, that Philip of all people is saying this?
1552年，当时十几岁的萨里·图帕克收到了一封信，同样是来自西班牙的腓力二世。他当时还不是腓力二世。他还是个王子。但腓力对他说，听着，我知道你父亲曼科是被挑衅才起义的。顺便说一句，腓力竟然会这么说，这难道不令人惊讶吗？
If you come out of your lair, I promise you a full pardon and we'll leave your little kingdom alone. But basically, I'd like you to come out. And this guy, Cyri Tupac, decided to accept. And he had travelled down by litter to the coast. He was greeted in Lima by the viceroy with great honour. He was lodged in the viceregal palace. He was given, they said, you know, thanks for coming out.
如果你从巢穴里出来，我保证给你全面赦免，我们会让你那个小王国独自存在。但基本上，我希望你出来。这个叫萨里·图帕克的人决定接受。他乘轿子前往海岸。他在利马受到了总督的隆重欢迎。他被安置在总督府。他们说，你知道，谢谢你出来。
We'll give you a big estate in the sacred valley outside Kusko. And amazingly, I love this. Pope Julius III gave him special dispensation to marry his sister. Yeah, I mean, he'll do it for the Inca, but not for Henry VIII. Yeah, what's all that about? That's Paul from the papacy, yes again. So the kingdom, the little, what they call the Neo-Inca kingdom, survived under his older half-brother who succeeded, who is Tito Kuzzi, the guy we've been hearing from, this amazing source, because he narrated this stuff to a Spanish missionary. Tito-A-goose, he actually is, without any question, the only basically really, really good person in this whole story.
我们会给你库斯科外圣谷的一大片庄园。令人惊讶的是，我喜欢这个。教皇朱利叶斯三世给了他娶自己妹妹的特别豁免权。是的，我的意思是，他会为印加人这样做，但不会为亨利八世这样做。是的，那到底是怎么回事？那是来自教皇的保罗，是的，又是这样。所以这个王国，他们所说的“新印加王国”，在他年长的同父异母兄弟继位后幸存下来，那就是蒂托·库西，我们一直听到的那个人，这个了不起的来源，因为他向一位西班牙传教士讲述了这些事情。蒂托·库西，他毫无疑问是整个故事中唯一一个基本上真正非常好的人。
So he ruled for basically a decade, the 1560s. And he said to his captains and whatnot, basically, we should do nothing to provoke the Spanish. would just completely leave them alone, will stay here in the jungle, and they'll leave us alone. And not only did he do that, he was very friendly to the Spanish. They would send missionaries and envoys,
所以他基本上统治了十年，即16世纪60年代。他对他的队长们之类的人说，基本上，我们不应该做任何挑衅西班牙人的事。我们只会完全不理会他们，我们会留在这里的丛林里，他们也会让我们独自存在。他不仅这样做了，而且对西班牙人非常友好。他们会派遣传教士和特使，
and he enjoyed chatting to them. He allowed them to put up a cross, all of this kind of thing. He allowed them to preach. He was baptized, although he continued to practice his own religion as well. And the Spanish reported that Tito Kuzzi was a large, very jolly man.
他很喜欢和他们聊天。他允许他们竖起十字架，所有这类事情。他允许他们传教。他受了洗，尽管他也继续实践自己的宗教。西班牙人报告说，蒂托·库西是一个身材魁梧、非常快乐的人。
He was a joker. He liked a lot of feathers and nice cloaks and stuff like this. And John Heming says, basically, if he had lived longer, Vilcabamba, and I quote, might have become an independent state under the direct protection of the Spanish ground. It might have related to Spanish Peru as Lesotho, Swaziland and Botswana related to South Africa. And Vilcabamba would now have a seat in the United Nations.
他是个爱开玩笑的人。他喜欢很多羽毛和漂亮的斗篷之类的东西。约翰·赫明说，基本上，如果他活得更久，比尔卡班巴，我引用一下，“可能已经成为西班牙王室直接保护下的一个独立国家。它可能与西班牙秘鲁的关系就像莱索托、斯威士兰和博茨瓦纳与南非的关系一样。而比尔卡班巴现在将在联合国拥有一席之地。”
That's a nice thought, isn't it? Is, isn't it? But he doesn't live. He goes to visit his father's shrine where his father had been murdered in Viccos. He catches a chill. He then makes a terrible mistake. He decides to have gone on a massive drinking bout and gets absolutely wasted on Chicha,
那是个美好的想法，不是吗？是，不是吗？但他没能活下去。他去参观他父亲在维科斯被谋杀的神龛。他着凉了。然后他犯了一个可怕的错误。他决定去进行一场大规模的酗酒狂欢，喝得烂醉如泥，喝的是奇恰酒，
and then he gets a fever and he dies. And he's succeeded by his brother, who has probably better known name, Tupac Amaru. Tupac Amaru was in his mid-twenters and he was a disaster for the Neo-Inca state because he was much less skillful than Tito Kuzi. He said, Tito Kuzzi's death was all the Christians' fault.
然后他发烧了，去世了。他的兄弟继位，名字可能更广为人知，图帕克·阿马鲁。图帕克·阿马鲁当时二十多岁，对新印加国来说是一场灾难，因为他比蒂托·库西笨拙得多。他说，蒂托·库西的死全是基督徒的错。
He should never have allowed all those missionaries in and done all this. He kills a friar, he outlaws Christianity, and he says, let's seal off Phil Cabamba from the outside world. So the viceroy at the time was Geico de Tledo, and he sent an envoy to protest with letters protesting from the Pope and the King of Spain. Philip II. Tupac Amaru did not welcome the envoy with open arms. He had him murdered on the border. The inevitable consequence, the viceroy proclaimed Tupac Amaru an apostate, a homicide, a rebel and a tyrant.
他本不该允许所有那些传教士进来并做所有这些事。他杀了一名修士，取缔了基督教，并说，让我们把比尔卡班巴与外界隔绝。当时的副王是弗朗西斯科·德·托莱多，他派了一名特使去抗议，带着教皇和西班牙国王腓力二世的抗议信。图帕克·阿马鲁并没有张开双臂欢迎这位特使。他在边境将其杀害。不可避免的后果是，副王宣布图帕克·阿马鲁为叛教者、杀人犯、叛乱分子和暴君。
and he called for a liberal interventionist War of Fire and Blood. I mean, a War of Fire and Blood, never good news. Never good news. The Spanish marched into the jungle in 1572 in June. This time, they find it all pretty easy. The Inca's have fled into the jungle, but they track them down. They capture Tupac Amaru, and they bring him back to Kusko,
他呼吁进行一场自由干预主义的“火与血之战”。我的意思是，一场火与血之战，从来都不是好消息。从来都不是好消息。西班牙人在1572年6月开进丛林。这一次，他们发现一切都很容易。印加人逃进了丛林，但他们追踪到了他们。他们俘虏了图帕克·阿马鲁，并将他带回库斯科，
together with the mummified remains of Manco and Tito Guzi. And Tupac Amaru is tried for rebellion. It's a show trial very like Atta Welper's. And like Atta Welper, he converts to Christianity, kind of in extremis. But just like Pizarro and Almagro with the death of Attawelper, the vicerroy wants to get rid of him, and he wants it done quickly. And so on the 24th of September 1572, the last king of the Inca's is led out into the square in Cusco. We're told that he was riding a mule with trappings of black velvet, and he himself was completely dressed in mourning. And as so often on these occasions there are colossal crowds. The Indians
连同曼科和蒂托·库西的木乃伊遗骸。图帕克·阿马鲁因叛乱受审。这是一场非常像阿塔瓦尔帕那样的作秀审判。像阿塔瓦尔帕一样，他在临终前皈依了基督教。但就像皮萨罗和阿尔马格罗在阿塔瓦尔帕死时一样，副王想除掉他，而且想尽快完成。于是，1572年9月24日，最后一位印加国王被带到库斯科的广场上。我们被告知，他骑着一头装饰着黑色天鹅绒的骡子，他自己也完全穿着丧服。正如在这种场合经常发生的那样，人群非常庞大。印第安人
climbed the walls and roofs of the houses and even the many large hills that are visible from the city were full of Indians. And he goes up onto the scaffold, Tupac Amaru. As the multitude of Indians saw that their Lord and Inca was to die, they deafened the skies, making them reverberate with their cries and wailing. And then he turns to the crowd and he says his last words in Ketchwa. Pacha Kamak, so the old creator god. see how my enemies spill my blood. And then with one blow, the executioner severed his head
爬上了房屋的墙壁和屋顶，甚至从城市里可以看到的许多大山丘上也挤满了印第安人。图帕克·阿马鲁走上断头台。当众多的印第安人看到他们的领主和印加王即将死去时，他们震耳欲聋的哭喊声让天空都为之回响。然后他转向人群，用克丘亚语说了他最后的遗言。帕查·卡马克，也就是古老的造物主神。看看我的敌人是如何流我的血的。然后，刽子手一刀砍下了他的头，
and held it high for all to see. And as the blow fell, the bells of the cathedral began to toll and they were followed by those of all the monasteries and churches in the city. The execution caused the greatest sorrow and brought tears to the eyes of all. And that was the end of the last of the Inkers.
并高高举起让所有人看到。当刀落下时，大教堂的钟声开始敲响，随后是城里所有修道院和教堂的钟声。这次处决引起了极大的悲痛，让所有人的眼中都流下了泪水。这就是最后一位印加人的结局。
Thank you, Dominic. What an incredible epic sweep. Thanks so much. A dark, but I mean, such a compelling story. And next week, a complete change of tone. We are in 18th century London for the story of Samuel Johnson and James Boswell, one of the great friendships in history. And nobody, I think, is killed in the course of that series at all.
谢谢你，多米尼克。多么令人难以置信的史诗篇章。非常感谢。一个黑暗的，但我的意思是，如此引人入胜的故事。下周，语调将完全改变。我们将进入18世纪的伦敦，讲述塞缪尔·约翰逊和詹姆斯·博斯韦尔的故事，这是历史上伟大的友谊之一。而且我认为，在那个系列的过程中根本没有人被杀。
So a real change of flavour, I think. it's fair to say. And members of the Restless History Club will get all four episodes of that on Monday. And if you're not a member, you know what to do. Sign up at the Restless History.com. But for now, thank you, Dominic, for an epic tale, epically told. Bye-bye. Muchas, gracias. Adios, machos. Hello, everybody, and welcome to the Book Club, a new podcast from Gollhanger. Hosted by me, Dominic Sambrook. And me, Tabitha Syrod. As some of you may know, I've been Dominic's producer,
所以我想说，这确实是一种口味的改变。这是公平的说法。Restless History Club的成员将在周一获得该系列的所有四集。如果你不是会员，你知道该怎么做。在Restless History.com注册。但现在，谢谢你，多米尼克，讲述了一个史诗般的故事，讲述得非常精彩。再见。非常感谢。再见，伙计们。大家好，欢迎来到“读书俱乐部”，这是Gollhanger推出的一个新播客。由我和多米尼克·桑布鲁克主持。还有我，塔比莎·赛罗德。正如你们中的一些人可能知道的那样，我一直是多米尼克的制片人，
on the rest of history. And we even did a mini-series last year about all things books. And since we enjoyed that so much, we have decided to roll it out as its own show. It will be coming out every Tuesday. We'll be doing a different book each time and digging into all the stories behind them. And we are going to be talking about the historical contexts behind some of the greatest and most famous books of all time. We're going to be digging into the remarkable people behind them, the unexpected stories behind the stories, and also unraveling the plot of each book a bit
在《Restless History》节目中。我们去年甚至做了一个关于书籍的迷你系列。因为我们非常喜欢那个节目，所以我们决定把它作为一个独立的节目推出。它将于每周二播出。我们每次都会做一本不同的书，并深入挖掘它们背后的所有故事。我们将讨论有史以来一些最伟大、最著名书籍背后的历史背景。我们将深入挖掘它们背后非凡的人物，故事背后的意外故事，并稍微梳理一下每本书的情节，
and delving into the depths of the story. Now, you don't have to have read the books to listen to the show, but we hope that by the end of each episode, you will be able to pretend to people that you've read them. That is the key thing. And either way, whether you read them or not, we hope that you'll learn lots of fascinating facts,
并深入探讨故事的深度。现在，你不必读过这些书也能收听这个节目，但我们希望在每一集结束时，你都能向别人假装你读过它们。这是关键所在。无论如何，无论你是否读过它们，我们都希望你能学到很多迷人的事实，
you'll do lots of great stories, and maybe Tabby, the odd laugh. We will be looking at thrilling, gothic bodice rippers like Wuthering Heights and Frankenstein, as well as iconic stories like The Great Gatsby or Little Women. And then also some more modern stuff. So Game of Thrones, Normal People, The Hunger Games, Hamlet, all manner of exciting stories.
你会听到很多精彩的故事，也许塔比，还会偶尔笑一笑。我们将关注惊悚的哥特式小说，如《呼啸山庄》和《弗兰肯斯坦》，以及像《了不起的盖茨比》或《小妇人》这样的标志性故事。然后还有一些更现代的作品。所以《权力的游戏》、《正常人》、《饥饿游戏》、《哈姆雷特》，各种令人兴奋的故事。
So please join us on our journey into all things books, wherever you get your podcasts. Just search for The Book Club every Tuesday, and hopefully we will see you there. Getting ready for a game means being ready for anything. Like packing a spare stick. I like to be prepared. That's why I remember 988, Canada's suicide crisis helpline.
所以请加入我们的书籍之旅，无论你在哪里收听播客。每周二搜索“读书俱乐部”，希望我们能在那里见到你。为比赛做准备意味着为任何事情做好准备。比如带一根备用球杆。我喜欢有备无患。这就是为什么我记住了988，加拿大的自杀危机求助热线。
It's good to know, just in case. Anyone can call or text for free confidential support from a train responder anytime. 988 suicide crisis helpline is funded by the government in Canada. Hello, I'm James Wood, and this year on the Close Reading's podcast from the London Review of Books, I'm asking, who's afraid of realism? I'll be taking a range of great novels and short stories from Flobert's Madame Bovary and Dostoevsky, notes from Underground, up to more recent works by Amit Chowdhury and Gwendolyn Riley, and I'll be examining what makes and makes for the real. How does realism produce its effects?
很高兴知道，以防万一。任何人都可以随时拨打或发短信，从训练有素的响应者那里获得免费的保密支持。988自杀危机求助热线由加拿大政府资助。你好，我是詹姆斯·伍德，今年在伦敦书评的“细读”播客上，我问，谁害怕现实主义？我将选取一系列伟大的小说和短篇小说，从福楼拜的《包法利夫人》和陀思妥耶夫斯基的《地下室手记》，到阿米特·乔杜里和格温多琳·赖利的近期作品，我将审视是什么造就了现实，以及现实是如何构成的。现实主义是如何产生其效果的？
And who is and has been afraid of realism, and why? If you subscribe to close readings, you'll get full access to the series, alongside all the other series we have running this year, about narrative poems, environmental writing, and a history of London, as well as our full archive covering literature and philosophy from ancient Greece to the present day. You can listen to free extracts and sign up for a seven-day free trial. Just search for close readings wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谁害怕现实主义，为什么？如果你订阅了“细读”，你将获得该系列的完整访问权限，以及我们今年运行的所有其他系列，关于叙事诗、环境写作和伦敦历史，以及我们涵盖从古希腊到现在的文学和哲学的完整档案。你可以收听免费片段并注册七天免费试用。无论你在哪里收听播客，只需搜索“细读”。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。